well you know Alcoholics Anonymous was
created by a guy who's into LSD yeah
Bill W a real mean bowler Jamie I want
to show you through your sweater and saw
a bad sweater
it's what shirt you're wearing it's very
cool but this is a this is a symptom of
everything is wrong go ahead are we on
yet
yeah we're on it's got fake short
sleeves it's got fake short sleeves over
long sleeves so the the short sleeves
are sewed in so that's not so it's not
attached how does it work then the short
sleeves are top it comes apart but this
sleeve part up there's not at all it's
separate so it's two pieces yeah I
didn't know that when I bought it either
but when you pull the sleeve up what
happens Oh goes all the way over the top
oh so do you wear the two of them
together or they I just saw it on I just
bought it there's a whole rocky thing
that this company did they had a whole
bunch of pieces and I was like oh that's
kind of cool
so Sylvester Stallone is slated to come
on the podcast you will wear that
correct and he's here please okay all
right so is that but that the upper
shirt is just laid over the tops shorts
long sleeve shirt so you could wear one
without the other like you could wear
the short sleeve 100 case just to
sweatshirts you know but it's a it's the
training montage oh it comes is it heavy
or is it light it is not light at all
I'm starting to sweat right now that we
should the store but that'll make you
stronger if you got a heavy shirt we are
here and if some [ __ ] goes down I may
have to bolt from the podcast yeah
because there's mandatory evacuations
all around here really yeah yeah what is
the word live all in Ventura County
there's all these mandatory of bees yeah
honey bees is it really yeah they're
making too much honey mudslides oh wow I
didn't know that yeah I had to pull off
La Cienega one time that a bunch of bees
on there what yeah huge hives man Wow
and you see you know a lot of homeless
people and they don't do anything but
when be show up
[ __ ] get to doing [ __ ] you know
that's one thing I noticed quickly yeah
yeah isn't it interesting how they get
motivated by bees yeah
these will motivate anybody yeah you
know you know you know you're not all
cracked out once the bees show up dude I
watch the bees communicate with each
other once I was on the set of Fear
Factor and we covered these people with
bees and then a neighboring colony a
colony that actually lived their local
colony came and we're like what are you
guys doing here and the bees all flew up
in the sky together and sorted it out in
the sky really was wild
we had the guy told us like the
beekeeper he's like everybody's gonna
stand down we got to back up get out of
the area
look what so yeah they have to
communicate I thought he was joking let
them do it huh yeah he's like they have
to talk it out like well they talk what
are they gonna say there's something
going on with them that we you know we
just kind of subtly we sort of get what
they do yeah yeah they're kind of like
little little kind of liaisons it seems
like like a wonderful in the future
we'll know that like certain animals can
like you know take messages around for
us and like if you told an animal
something could go tell you know like I
wonder if we'll start using animals more
because animals are we don't use them
that much I mean they were sitting
around most of the time right I've read
something about they were trying to
encode information in DNA we could ask
Mike Tyson about his pigeons yeah I
think that's different though Kerri
edges up attentions just to carry for
long how about Game of Thrones yeah Sam
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure but
whatever for whatever reason it makes
more sense with birds Yeah right like a
bird seems like you should be able to
train it a little bit Oh bird you could
train some birds I think some birds I
think would do their own thing let me
ask you this if you had an important
message would you just send one raven
that's what I never got how about you
sent a fly what are you crazy
look at that god damn think it's eaten
what have an eagle Jack someone along
the way the fate of your kingdom is at
hand sir yeah yeah he can't put that on
the back of one bird did I would send a
bird nobody would expect you know like a
little Warbler something on nightingale
oh that's a good move yeah you got to
send a bird that nobody wants to shoot
though you like to shoot birds
I will - dude we had owl two
Thanksgivings ago we had two hours at my
sister's house yeah I saw one last night
actually did you yeah it was pretty no
no lesson tonight before us it was
pretty [ __ ] cool I pulled into the
driveway and owl took off it was big -
it's gross I think owls the meat the oh
you ate them you saying
yeah but the he has a towels yeah I
think that's legal I shouldn't say that
on the podcast well I didn't have a lot
Murray used to have a joke about it I
don't know - I don't know even spit it
out I'm not even joking you smoke that
weed and they had to they didn't have
all the thing they don't have a lot of
meat on them it there I [ __ ] know
like owls they're predators they're
important yeah you don't have rats
everywhere yeah but you know they're I
think they're violent then they're dirty
and they they get this owls whoever did
their PR you notice everybody thinks
they're smart and they can read and
they're like yeah they had a good PR
yeah right yeah look at that we only got
one up Jimmy but see how much little
meat is on him you think there's more
look at he's kidding he's kidding folks
he's not eating owls the one in the
middle looks like it's from another
planet you know yeah yeah and that's
what that's what it really looks like
that's what it looks like underneath all
that fluff
yeah little alien Raptor creature I was
like a crab looks like a crab I was
driving home when one was flying above
me on the road and dropped a rabbit he
had got a rabbit and jacked it and was
flying with the rabbit and as he was
flying just decided like maybe he
decided the car was too close to him
what was too loud or somebody they just
dropped that rabbit [ __ ] it and I
stopped the car and check it out I was
like whoa this flirting really it sounds
like flirting how alert drops a rabbit
at your feet a [ __ ] yeah it's ready to
[ __ ]
probably yeah like an offering look at
God for you more with that came the
Predators man they we never thought of
them growing up as predators yeah that's
why they told us they were wise they had
to have that monocle like [ __ ] like
Budd Friedman yeah need the improv
remember like that planners peanut Budd
Friedman from evening
improv his whole deal was yeah no I was
I loved evening the improv when I was a
kid or saw it oh man that was like one
of the reasons where I got into stand-up
comedy I still watch these TV shows they
had syndicated TV shows that they would
do you know vh1 had won MTV at the
half-hour comedy hour and what time did
it come on it
I don't remember man you don't remember
that was Budd but it was probably night
he looks like that planners nut but
angry when that guy was one of the
owners he sold it eventually and
chicheng cashed out got from Brian
Friedman in the left corner oh that's a
different dude yeah interesting a lot of
Friedman's out there but anyway Budd ran
he was the host of evening at The Improv
and he would come out with that monocle
go back to that monocle picture again
lower-left BAM
that was him see you see Google Budd
Friedman evening at the improv that's
what it okay
yeah nice guy real real nice guy yeah he
was yeah a real nice guy oh he's always
a sweetheart to me always very very
friendly he was a very gregarious guy
and he basically was one of the original
owners of the improv and evening at the
improv I don't know I don't know the
full history of the improv I probably
should but I think I want to say it
started out New York yeah because I know
there were there were ones everywhere at
one point time they had one in Boston
for a little bit and improv yeah yeah
they had one in Boston and then they
changed it to a different name yeah it
started Hell's Kitchen in 1963 yeah so
that was probably one of the original
stand-up comedy clubs probably one of
the top two or three do you have a
favorite like a club when you were like
doing clubs more together like a
favorite one I was just happy to get on
stage back then you know I mean I had
favorite ones like Nick's comedy stopped
was always a favorite in Boston right
stitches but stitches moved a couple of
times
stitches moved twice what about any of
the funny buns or did you go to any of
those places
yeah but the arc for the Boston clubs
the comedy connection was the big one
and now that's the Wilbur theater it's
really weird because it used to be the
smallest club in town and everybody
wanted to work it it was like a hundred
whoa I want to say they get stuff maybe
150 people in there but I mean ain't
stuffed I mean this room this this
ceiling was low you know I mean I'm 5/8
and I remember I could a pretty sure I
could touch the ceiling
so this [ __ ] is low so if you were like
Owen Smith yeah or you know someone talk
about a long haul yeah like yeah it's a
big ass stage for you like big people
would look real weird on that stage
yeah but the laughs would be so
contained it was no low ceiling and
tight I love that I love hey I saw Hicks
there for the first time first time I
ever saw him was there I was like whoa
he was doing this bit about Jimi Hendrix
meeting Tiffany at the mall Tiffany the
ama singer oh yeah the shoes real
popular then I think we're alone oh yeah
yeah that song I make you just be a
wreck I remember being on the school bus
so [ __ ] erect bra dude I remember
that [ __ ] bro did I love being erect and
I was young man now it's whatever
now it's whatever now I have to do
something now what do you know what does
my dick need me to do
right so you eat now yeah so I'll tell
you this if you want to feed a family of
four you can't just have one hour I will
say that huh well if you look at what it
looks like without the feathers it looks
like some same [ __ ] demon yeah you
know it's a real bait and switch I feel
like it's one of God's hidden agendas
well I was talking to someone about
peacocks about this I started talking
about on stage like peacocks are pretty
but if it took their feathers off you'd
want to kill it with a hammer yeah what
is that
[ __ ] is that it wouldn't let that thing
anywhere near your kids well look yeah
ox have their feathers on you let your
kids get right close to them oh yeah but
beauty talk with no feathers yeah dark
skin like charcoal cover this Garrity
and the little nubs all over it oh look
[ __ ] look at dad looks like he's a lame
murderer
looks like a little twink out on the
town a little creepy murder a little
probably a little gray and pink murderer
well is that what it looks like what
Maine
oh whoa is that real oh my yeah that's a
duck bro it says pecan right
[ __ ] picture they have a different head
go back to that peacock picture that you
just have home line okay that's a
totally different head Leah beak shape
different yes beautiful head that's the
problem with the internet yeah okay then
so hard to tell that's a duck son who is
yeah yeah those are ducks maybe it's on
that page or something like that well it
says right there said feathers ripped
from live birds didn't ripping the
feathers off peacock yo Hicks a nice guy
what was he like that you need to meet
him I met him like hi oh yeah hey
so I was I was an open mic er oh yeah
you know he ain't gonna talk to me yeah
it's like you know I say hi to everybody
I've run into like door guys I always
try to say hi to everybody yeah cuz I
remember what it was like when I was an
open mic ER and seeing these guys who I
couldn't even talk I couldn't even
imagine that we were the same thing mmm
couldn't talk to them you know what I
mean the big comedians you mean [ __ ]
yeah like Bill Hicks would come into
town I didn't want to say hi to him
gonna be super annoying right cuz then
what are you back it up but that was
always my thing I was so stupid back
then too I'm not pretty dumb now but I
was really done back then yeah there was
no way I had anything to say to that
dude you think there was a time you life
you were the dumbest that you'd ever
been a couple weeks ago no I don't know
man but I definitely have more data to
work with now but I forgotten a lot of
[ __ ] too but like you think there's
generally a time in people's lives when
they what they should know kind of and
the there's like a kind of like a middle
ground where maybe it doesn't well for
sure when I was in my early 20s for sure
when I was in my 20s like deep into my
you know it took me into my 30s to kind
of [ __ ] [ __ ] shake my head loose and
figure out what the [ __ ] I was doing
yeah dude you're 20 bro when you think
about twenties right no Direction no
idea whether or not this comedy thing
was gonna work out I'm like what am i
doing yeah I'm telling jokes Jesus
Christ yeah and then telling people when
you go back home and they've never seen
you they've never heard of you they
think you're gay it's like you won't
like they're like you keep flying home
you don't have any money and you're not
bringing a girl home
yeah these jokes yeah you're hiding from
something you know just
come out I remember my stepdad he's
yelling at me in the yard one time so
what did you come out yeah I was like
I'm not [ __ ] gay bro like I'm just
not flying some girl home that I just
met you know just to prove to you guys
catch it a lie
yeah thought maybe he was gonna leave eh
yeah like I set a trap yeah he's gonna
set a trap yeah I was setting a trap
yeah he's like a slick boxer that's one
of the reasons why young boys will
always accuse each other being gay
because it's so hard to prove you're not
yeah what someone says you're gay yeah
you take that off me
either that's crazy if the worst has got
to be if someone says you're gay and you
are but you don't want to oh yeah at
least yet yeah you change your clothing
next day he'd come dressed like in a
Mafia outfit or something like something
- totally
take him hot off the trail you know you
just wish you could say you were yeah
you know you wish you could say you were
I think now you can I think I think she
can a lot of places
I mean I would love to think that
everybody's like the people that are
around us where they literally don't
give a [ __ ] yeah Justin Martindale or
look our language is funny and after
that it's cool to be around those are
the things that are most valuable in our
world funny and cool to be around right
those two things okay someone's funny
and cool to be around we don't give a
[ __ ] if you're a guy or girl trans gay
yeah
funny ghost cool the beer yeah do you
think this ghost at the Comedy Store I
III don't know I have some friends or
the other day I was trying to give them
the whole tour yeah I tell them how it
used to be Ciro's nightclub on it I
didn't take them all the way but I
showed them you know you go through the
back room of the main room that that
used to be like their hideout and [ __ ] I
told them about all the ghost stories
that have been filmed there but I don't
believe it I don't think it's real well
I think I'm surprised we don't have more
ghosts
you know what I think I think it's you
this is what I think for real I think
when you I think you can probably tune
in to something that happened in a place
that's what I think and I think if you
trip yourself out you could see things
that aren't really there
and I think that it is entirely possible
the ghosts aren't real but that you
seeing a ghost is real yeah that I think
that you can get your body into like
such a frenzied terrified state and if
you are open to the idea that the ghost
is a real thing your mind can [ __ ] with
you yeah like the ghetto boys your
mind's playing tricks on me yeah that's
what I think
I think legitimately and I also think
that if you hit the right frequency I
bet you get whole ups like it's just a
ghost of a memory of someone getting
killed in a place right or something
horrible happening just the ghost of a
memory no I think that's next that's one
of the next things you're gonna be able
to do like a gang sign in the air a
special gang sign and then a [ __ ] the
truth is gonna pop out right in front of
you like I think we're gonna start to
learn a Harry Potter type [ __ ] yes or
like maybe a song what if the sir a
certain like playing of us lyrics hurt
our notes in a row would reveal like the
past right in front of you like I wonder
if there's some you know magic little
warp holes or something well well think
about what music does do music literally
changes the way your body feels like a
drug like if you were a kid okay and you
heard that rocky song dah dah dah dah
dah dah dah dah dah dah dah dah dah you
could run faster you would get more
fired up you'll be able to do more
push-ups or let your step there don't
say it do it yeah but you will probably
a lot of dudes probably but the point is
you would for sure get energy from that
like a drug
yes that was a cup of coffee and go like
whoa this coffee is good right you hear
that song yeah put up that video the
other day oh yeah that I reposted
vibrations and yeah if you look deep
into this topic of vibrations and
symbols that come out and like explain
what we're talking about the I posted it
on my Instagram I reposted it because
it's really fascinating this is black
man it's it seems like it's just a mat
that's charged yeah
vibrated let's explain what's happening
for the people who just not gonna play
this video cuz they're probably taking
down it's got a lot of views there's
lots of different versions of this
online it says amazing amazing amazing
resonance experiment so they put some
st. as its and this is probably salt
okay they put some sort of powdered
stuff sand or salt onto a black mat
that's charged and then they send
certain Hertz through it this one's 3835
Hertz and then it makes a different
patterns crazy on the look at this 3975
like every time they change the Hertz it
has a different paddle the 4049 look at
this pattern so the spirits are wait
that's unbelievable but yeah and these
are also you can take these numbers and
these can also be notes that's a dark
evening on a piano or used to hearing or
singing right so these can also be
recreated in other ways and are probably
happening right and to us you know
that's not like maybe one of those
earworm here like Victor you're in the
back your neck vibrate or something like
that
what if a certain Hertz just spelled
you're like your grandparents name well
what's interesting is that each one of
them are different geometric patterns
there are these beautiful patterns
they're gorgeous and as you change the
Hertz the patterns morph immediately
yeah and but the thing is they're kind
of fractal like not fractal but they
they seem to be what's the word e equal
in both sides is that way that this word
I'm looking for
mmm parallel no no I think you were
you're on the right topic if the numbers
a little more round like a round number
these are not specific Hertz like if you
do a specific likes winds different than
identical but anyway both sides are
exactly the same and it's separate in
this one they're not it's not separated
in a half it's it's it's all like the
circle is the center it all goes out
from there but they're different every
time but they're all even like see it
looks the only thing that's keeping it
from being perfect is that they run out
of sand and it looks like the power is
centered around the center part where
the wires are connected to so that's the
most potent but silicon beautiful so
that may like thing if you think about
that like in a
if there's a certain Hertz going through
the air like in space yeah then it would
form like a solar system I guess one
better the feeling that you get from
like Rocky right the feeling that you
get from that saw that things go your
body yes
yeah it could literally could be like a
little drug look think about why people
like music so much because that musician
is your drug deal yeah okay you hear
like some old Elton John like you're in
your car and Saturday night comes on
your [ __ ] goosebumps if you haven't
heard that song in a long time and you
don't expect it yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
Jesse had a friend that what makes you
want a hat you know that's a good song -
yeah but five is good this was done with
Mike I was staying with musical notes
Wow on water we're looking at the thing
it says the cyma scope is that how you
say that saya cym a scope uses a high
definition camera to monitor the effects
of an individual sounds particular
vibrations on purified water revealing
for the first time what piano notes look
like ah there are people out there so
much more than you and me oh yeah oh god
it's it's amazing that we're considered
the same thing you know as what smart
people just really smart people yeah I
have someone like Sean Carolyn the
physicist and he has to break down
particle physics and [ __ ] to you you
like is it hard it doesn't even get in
yeah does it I can repeat what he said
yeah I don't the [ __ ] it means when
people start talking about quantum
things in quantum theory and quantum
particles as danger dude I don't get I
don't trust that kind of stuff a lot of
it
well how about you know what
superposition is it's the ultimate what
the [ __ ] or a particle can be in the
state of motion and be still at the same
time all right well good luck with that
good luck yeah this magic world that
you've created crazy scientists that I
don't understand yeah I would rather do
something more chill than that
what the [ __ ] something can see yeah
sign up like or go for a run or
something
Oh being rather than study that or
rather than be that particle oh rather
than study that in bit yeah like I just
think but don't you want someone to know
because don't you benefit from
cellphones well what about the such few
people know that if they all wanted to
lie to us then they could they would
have to be conspiracy now you starting
to sound like some other people it's
funny that your body would do that the
reason why they would never do that is
because scientists whole deal is
figuring out [ __ ] that other scientists
didn't figure out that's like the best
thing they can do the best thing a
scientist can do is a real
honest-to-goodness breakthrough would
you have sex with a scientist you think
yeah like a movie scientists like she
keeps the glasses on yeah they're always
blonde in the movies right
sorry no sometimes a dark black hair too
mysterious I bet they're clean
- if you [ __ ] a scientist you know I bet
they have a clean apartment maybe but
maybe not maybe their [ __ ] brain is
like that chalkboard with all the
squiggly alien mathematics are that's
true huh what [ __ ] tattoo does a bunch
of dirty math tattooed on their puss I
was reading another but I was reading
this things about Richard Fineman you
know who Fineman was fine was a
scientist he was a physicist and there
was an article about him like was
Fineman an abuser but it was it was
talking about Richard Fineman and how
you know he's - you just his wife said
he's just do nothing but calculations
all day and then he wanted to play the
bongos and he didn't want anybody to
bother him but like he had a quote from
one of his one of his books and it's
crazy reading and it's like I just but
see if he could find it because it's a
really it's a crazy quote calling women
[ __ ] and I'm like what like that
there were that that you know I just I
don't want to paraphrase he's like I
don't I don't I can't deal with these
[ __ ] around here so I think he was a
funny guy right what I think it's hard
it's hard when you see things in text
because you think okay maybe he's like a
really mean terrible person
I adopted the attitude that those bar
girls are all [ __ ] that they aren't
worth anything and that they're all in
the all they're in there for is for to
get you to buy him a drink and they're
not going to give you a goddamn thing
I'm not gonna be a gentleman to such
worthless [ __ ] and so on he writes C
but I feel like and so on when someone
says and so on that implies that this is
taken out of context what does that mean
and so on that means to me what I'm
getting out of this if I if I was gonna
guess is that he goes on he elaborates
mmm he might say this is how I felt back
then and obviously I changed my mind I
mean he could have been eighteen when
you talk about this or sixteen I don't
know what the [ __ ] right but he also
could be very funny because he was
apparently a very funny guy hmm
so his the the title of his book is
surely you're joking mr. Fineman
oh that's nice then but if it was so
like if one if someone said that but
adopting all these bar girls or [ __ ]
if they said it funny mm-hmm could you
see those those same more yeah I thought
that all these balls are the [ __ ] but
it's all depending upon how old he is -
or it could be that that's really how he
was and maybe he got married maybe got
in trouble his wife and he had to say
this you know I don't think that's it I
think he's talking about when he was
younger but it's um I could see that
though do you're at the bar if you don't
like we're allowed music and all the
girls are just drinking with a bunch of
and I would be like oh these girls are a
bunch of [ __ ] probably yeah but
that's a lazy way it is a lazy way thing
and it just makes it it's you can judge
and you can control the scenario yeah
thing is look if you go into a room and
ten girls are in there and seven of them
are [ __ ] super annoying and you say
these [ __ ] are all annoying you're
being super rude to those three that
aren't yeah and there might be some
decent girls but that's why it's weird
yeah it's like it's weird to hear a
high-level famous scientist probably
that I think in the article they were
saying the second fit yeah beyond beyond
Einstein he's the second famous most
famous physicist especially a scientist
because you think a scientist would know
that there's a couple of these [ __ ]
could be variable right you know I am
thinking this might have been a quote
from him when he was young yeah
that's crazy that he said that or him
criticizing himself when he's young but
I don't know I'm just guessing I was
hoping that it would be that bad it's
crazy to read that dude a lot sometimes
I miss being young man don't you miss it
sometimes
well no and yes like it looks like fun
to have no responsibility in to be 22
and be backpacking around the world or
doing something silly and not having a
place where you have to go or a bunch of
bills but on the other hand I feel so
[ __ ] ridiculously lucky that I get to
be a comedian right like I don't want to
try to do this again yeah why would I
try to do this when I'm doing this but
yeah but to go back I just miss being
young and like remember a nap man we
took a nap and you were young it could
last you [ __ ] didn't care could last
for three days yes but I think one of
the secrets to happiness is to never
look back at any point in your life and
wish you were back there because a it's
not possible right and B if you didn't
go through that you wouldn't be you if
you would go back now and be 22 again
and broke and [ __ ] up with all the
information you have now he'd be like
[ __ ] y'all don't know
I had a [ __ ] Netflix special you guys
don't know I was killing it out there I
decided to start over like an [ __ ]
now here I am oh yeah I'm young but I'm
broke I can't even afford vitamins your
right feet at the right food I can't
afford AMA noodle I'm eating ramen
noodle everyday I'm gonna start breaking
joints yeah tear muscles and [ __ ] you're
gonna be eat now yeah [ __ ] catch
squirrels in my yard that's when it gets
bad I'm not used to being yelled at
either
I miss my body being young dude
how old are you I'm 38 shut your mouth
you're fine you just got a workout yeah
you don't workout huh I just started
getting back into it yeah that's all it
is doing some yoga and I want to go try
but resilient yet sit downtown slow down
with that tear yourself in shape first
yeah that's what I'm realizing my yeah
my advice because if you trying to
explode and get out of things look don't
listen to me you can start you Jitsu and
be in terrible shape and get in shape
through jujitsu you can yeah absolutely
but if I was going to advise someone I
would say if you're gonna do something
that's as physical as jujitsu I believe
that you should armor your body what I
mean by that is like your shoulders your
knees your back your neck those are all
areas that if you don't work out at all
they could break susceptible they're
susceptible so yeah I would always
advise that someone does a bunch of
calisthenics particularly like like the
classics push-ups sit-ups bodyweight
squats chin-ups
those all those classics you do a lot of
those get you just get your body
accustomed to resistance training right
do that first then I would move from the
I would always start with a but with
calisthenics always start with that and
then from that move into weights do like
some kettlebells take a couple of months
you could take a couple months before
you just jump right into jiu-jitsu if
you don't have but if you're an athlete
I mean you could just jump right in
right if you're a guy already does
basketball you already wrestle oh yeah
jump right in but a guy who doesn't do
any exercise at all yeah Jiu Jitsu so
rough on you yeah I used to do exercise
I'm and I used to do they we used to
shoot up steroids on the side of the
interstate when I was growing up shoot
on the side of the road why wouldn't you
go home I was more of an outdoor thing I
felt like you know I don't want to bring
that [ __ ] in the house but we would uh
me and a buddy - do Billy conforto
actually and he passed away r.i.p and he
died he had a bunch of pills and
actually drove into an embankment one
time but um no oh yeah can you imagine
some bad way to go and he but he was a
busboy and I was a busboy and he would
uh and yet we both like to go to the gym
and he was like the first gay man that
ever met and then he um you know he one
time he got us some steroids or
something
I don't know I think everybody was doing
them and then we just yeah we pull over
and do and then just go to the gym you
know do one time a guy in New York's I
don't want to get some drugs the middle
of the night he went came back three
hours later with steroids
he's like you want to walk in party Wow
who's partying Mysterio like fog no bro
okay I'm leaving tomorrow in New York I
was there for about eight months how
come so I was just kind of trying out
the comedy scene there and see what it
was like why'd you decide to leave mmm I
don't know I guess that's one of like a
new here's what it was I never wanted to
get old and say that I didn't try it to
go to LA to try New York - oh right -
never have even just six months even
just have like an experience there you
know well it's a hotbed for sure the two
hot beds right now are here and there
yeah those are two hot beds and there's
all this debate as to like which one's
better or whatever it's silly it's
that's a great hot bed yeah no denying
that there's some world-class comedians
over there and then there's ones that
show up there and here like Chappelle
he's always bounce bouncing back and
forth Chris Rock was always bouncing
back before Louie would news worked in
in here but Louie's working again he's
working at The Improv right now Lucy
Kane
San Jose yeah oh wow that's cool I think
he's gonna sell out a world tour in like
a year for sure for sure her next month
even if we wanted to yeah for sure you
know I mean it's it's interesting this
whole bit about the parklands shooting
you know you know yeah so that stirred
up all this controversy that is so
that's such a louis c.k bit it's
interesting it's almost like people
don't understand what kind of comedy he
did right
yeah like suddenly they forget who he
was yeah if you look at his comedy
you're not even surprised he was jerking
off you know kind of room service sort
of deal you know but he's he's his style
has always been like that
I mean that he's his style is always
very irreverent yeah saying [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you can't believe he's saying and
you know well written and well thought
out stuff this is stuff he's working on
and this is people like you know how
could he joke it wasn't even that good
he probably wrote it that day okay two
days before who knows how many times
done that bit but I guarantee you the
guy takes ten months off of stand-up
and then he's starting to do it again I
don't he was scared I bet I don't think
I would ever joke around about that I
definitely wouldn't joke around about
but you can yeah Nate I don't know if I
would it just wasn't it wasn't his best
stuff it wasn't good it's like it wasn't
ready yeah but maybe he could have come
up with a different turn on it where it
wouldn't be as offensive and it would be
way funnier that's what working on a bid
is all about right like [ __ ]
look Holtzman Brian Holtzman if he had
said that exact same thing that Louis
said we would be howling yeah we'd be in
the back of the room slapping the table
howl and laughing yeah could you put the
[ __ ] fat kid in the way literally I
love that guy that's a bit though if
Holtzman said we would be crying we'd be
slapping the table we'd all gather
around and watch him write late nights
would be an issue right it wouldn't be
an issue at all because we know that
it's humor is it yeah it's a [ __ ] up
thing to say that's kind of the point
the whole art form is about saying
things that are funny sometimes saying
things that are funny are
self-deprecating so sometimes they're
[ __ ] up yeah they're always different
sometimes saying things is they're funny
is really adorable yeah someone will say
something it's real adorable but also
hilarious yeah or your act this is odd
odd and hilarious just very very Theo
von yeah if I had to describe your act
I'd say it's very Theo von really yeah
it's you you know how to do it but it's
like everybody does it different folks
and you know you take a set from someone
who's just working stuff out and you
pretend that this is done he's probably
half those words he's saying he's
probably trying to be in the moment he's
probably got a place to go kind of got
some punchlines and hoping that he'll
see something in it while he's doing it
and working it out yes and then you
listen to the recording and you go why
did I say it that way why did I do this
and you change that and add this and
it's it's to learn yeah and then you
know it just can't expect them all to be
good either
like immediately especially when the
guys been on trial like you know or been
you know under that social pressure and
or just like you know in
you know probably been dealing with
remorse and going to self I don't know I
mean who knows what he's been doing this
is mine this is my take on a lot of this
and I think this is an important thing
to say we can't lose our empathy we
can't lose our compassion we have we
have we should be compassionate towards
victims we could we should be
compassionate towards each other we
should be this this tendency to want to
stop people from working and being like
there's a certain amount of time where
it passes and it starts to look like you
don't want anyone to have a path to
redemption right which is everyone's got
to have a path to read have to because
we're all faulty yeah all human but
there was an article about it that I
just retweeted today from Nick
Christakis who is a professor at Yale
i retweeted it today earlier in its
about call out culture and these people
that got called out for things and how
it destroyed their lives people that you
don't even know yeah it's one small park
scene where these these two people got
called out for stuff but it's like with
a subscription that got us with the
subscription hmm gotta subscribe in New
York Times bro you got to pay for good
journalism I pay mmm this account
actually if you want to use much you
have you have a times I don't I think I
do I had one but I tried to renew the
other day and I couldn't because these
[ __ ] stole my [ __ ] American Express
card and I didn't get my new one yet who
did the people where some [ __ ]
piece-of-shit criminals yeah charged up
[ __ ] one of them was Toys R Us in India
oh wow okay good I love seeing what
people charge when they do steal from
you it's kind of fun isn't it isn't it
crazy you're like pissed that they stole
be like oh wow alignment was one dollar
they got an ottoman a lot of it was a
one dollar
Cronos like what are you doing if you
bang that maybe they bang the card out
for like a hundred $1 or maybe it's got
a snatch knows you're running places to
get a snack get a gum get uh it was all
it was all online you know uh I bought a
ricci or something the other day was 88
cents yeah that would be a stupid thing
to hit someone's card for you'd want to
get a jewel yeah really expensive a pen
yeah I'm up for that 29 bucks how crazy
though that that that's the future that
now it's like that like I was thinking
the other day that having a baby inside
of your body this was gonna be like the
last yeah that's becoming retro y'all
they're gonna take it out for sure there
was a baby that was born today inside
the amniotic sac did you see that mmm
that's a damn goldfish it oh it's crazy
you see the delicacy in some places
inside the sack I mean I don't know what
the story was cuz I I'm a notorious
headline reader I read headlines I just
googled it and there's there's it's not
a thing
if hats happens apparently well I don't
know if it happens all the time I wanted
to get incredible photos of babies born
um but it was an article that was going
around the internet today baby born in
it's a video of the baby moving around
inside this this sac it's very weird
that's a Dan got it on YouTube that's a
dumpling dude if you're downtown what is
it's a dumpling it's they're very small
it's not a while see if you can find it
it was all I saw it I believe I saw it
on Instagram let me see that baby man do
you think maybe when babies are born
right when they're born look at that
though that's the same thing that's the
baby inside the sack that's one of those
things they eat is to eat sometimes on
those game shows oh so I'm guessing this
is a cesarean section happens once every
eighty thousand births that is amazing
that you could see what the baby looks
like when it's in there holy crap that's
incredible bro oh it's mannish it was in
Spain human beings making human beings
that's crazy this is exactly what I saw
this is this one it's exact when I saw
how crazy is that might be upsetting for
some you're about to see the Amiata
exact being opened the old man upsetting
that's how we exist yeah but people
aren't ready for life we're gonna keep
you from life we're gonna keep you from
everything there it is man the sack oh
[ __ ]
kids from now we could see a little bit
of butt on that one oh lordy
yeah I can't believe do you ever think
that maybe if a baby is born a certain
way like missionary or doggy style that
it could affect the way that they live
their life I thought about that before
well you should probably understand how
babies are born they have to come out
headfirst the baby comes out doggystyle
you got to spin them around inside the
womb literally okay but what if the
person is doggy style when they have the
baby though Oh different thing yeah you
kids probably gonna be a freak yeah
doggy styles like we're not making love
we're [ __ ] yeah doggy style is
basically us kind of Pat yeah it's like
getting to know each other quickly well
it's just a different kind of [ __ ]
yeah it's like oh this is a dirty [ __ ]
yeah it's fast or slow sometimes it
depends on how you're feeling sometimes
I miss sex when a young man sober sex is
for [ __ ] kit is for what is this with
you missing your youth I just love love
being what are you doing I don't want to
watch a lady give birth you son of a
[ __ ] she's giving birth in a river it's
cold in the river you crazy [ __ ] that's
melted glaciers that's that wim HOF
earth poor little kid and if it's not
warm if it's not that it's warm and if
it's warm it's fill with bacteria
[ __ ] no no you can't have a baby in your
bathtub if you live in [ __ ] Brooklyn
down the street don't you love your kid
yeah lady first of all she is uh she's
an Australia well this fighters that are
gonna crawl into her [ __ ] right now and
kill the baby before it even comes out
they have seven of the eight most
dangerous snakes in the world are in
Australia trying to tell my friend Adam
Greentree yesterday doesn't want to
believe me very the brown snake got
strand brown snake dude kill this [ __ ]
I'll kill that little [ __ ] Creek
[ __ ] speaking Australian brown snake
that's how she got pregnant in the first
place
dude a lot of my sister ones got knocked
up my brother once man I'll never know
yeah almost hi what's almost he [ __ ]
her I mean I don't know if they [ __ ]
but they well that's almost they were
thinking about baby names so I assumed
that they had had some type of
interaction oh so they were gonna do it
on purpose
I don't know I think that they're
thinking about baby names in case they
[ __ ] up boy that's some weird planning
ahead how much wear a condom er but I
think that's a dude's move if you think
you might have knocked a girl up and you
still want to stay with there you like
oh let's talk about baby names you know
I'm saying until you ride out there
until you bail that menstrual cycle know
until you know that the menstrual cycle
yeah you know yeah he's a little single
on a full moon or not it's a weird thing
if you are you're having sex with
somebody and you like having sex with
them but you don't like hanging out with
them yeah that happens for guys and
girls yeah that means for a lot of guys
I know dude it happens Saint girls too
it happens I've heard girls say that
like I don't even like hanging out with
them anymore but I like [ __ ] them
it's changing now and a lot more girls
are being very much like guys used to be
well they can be the first the birth
control pill then dating apps they can
get ahold of people spend money yeah now
they have options yeah but the thing
about this about dating apps it's like
that's gotta be just as weird as dating
for a girl yeah almost weird or maybe
right because you can't even see the
person right I mean you can see pictures
of them yeah but you don't see them when
they're looking at your profile in there
right you should be able to see how they
look at your profile how many people are
looking at your profile in any given
moment no that's a that's a nightmare
and of itself yeah we think about that
imagine like just people just looking at
you and saying no and you're in the
distance all the time it has to be bad
for us
somebody'll say yes in the odds the
thing is you're playing the numbers
maybe in that sense it's better because
the only people that get to hold you the
people that say yes right so you miss
all the knows that's true but what I was
gonna say is that haven't had a baby
with someone that you don't really like
yeah that's a possibility if you just
like to have sex with them and then
you don't like I gotta go yeah you can't
go cuz the babies around
he's gonna have [ __ ] buddies that
everyone else guys and girls have [ __ ]
buddies yeah I'm almost everyone I know
has had one in the past where you
weren't in a relationship with them
really my drive over and [ __ ] and bang
and then alright bye mwah yeah bye
but you kiss at the end that's a lot of
chicks these days I think they just want
to see they don't want to kiss someone
only want to see you sometimes you open
the door the girls they're ready to [ __ ]
and then just walks off in the other
direction we puts a blindfold on you
bird boxes when you're done with us man
they're done I feel like they're done do
you feel like that I think it's a
precarious time a lot of chicks are
probably going lesbo this week
oh it's dude I would be with Trump I
think the the more days that the the
government is shut down the more women
are gonna go lesbian they hate men so
much because of Trump yeah go gay but
people always gay people right now going
that's not how uh never what I said
earlier about jokes but if what's funny
to me is gay guys are always like I'm
gonna turn this guy out and that always
sounds I was learning that does work but
that sounds alarming it does sound
alarming but it does work
I have once a Almo said his name he
worked on she wasn't he's not an actor
but he worked in the world of acting and
he told me that he blew a lot of
straight guys mm-hmm it said that was
just something that happened they would
have a couple drinks and pretend they'd
never done it before next thing you know
yeah I got that delicious mouth that's
what a lot of gay dudes say it was
either him doing them or them doing him
but he's like you'd be amazed at how
many you know air quotes straight guys
are out there my womb yeah he just knows
how to swing it but would you do you
think is it less homosexual to jerk a
guy off with your left hand what are you
left-handed right hand right handed see
if he turns you off your left hand it's
it's gayer to do it with your right hand
it's care to do with my left hand the
one that doesn't work as well because
it'll take longer yeah but you don't
really have but it's understandable
like it's understandable if you do with
your left hand because
it's bear leaving your hand it's my hand
bro you're not gonna feel that much of
it though jerk them off with your right
hand so you should be effective and get
it done with unless you like holding on
the dicks longer don't know what's gonna
happen you're gonna come the knockin
wanna hang out with me anymore no I
would do that just go faster no I don't
believe you
yeah I think no I think you I think you
I think using that left hand is that rid
that's the party move you know because
it's not you could still use this hand
to be on your phone you can do other
stuff yeah but then you're not
concentrating on the jerk in the guy off
look once you commit to doing something
gay just get it done son yeah to get
after it that's true
you don't want to be out there while
you're pretending that you're looking at
your mentions okay but also what about
this though if you are aggressively very
effectively jerking off right and then
you can barely use your phone it looks
like you're just like a maybe a you know
gay or bi gentleman it's on some dope or
something you doing gay [ __ ] with your
on your phone okay I think I sound like
it acts as a condom to prevent you in
gayness you're doing gate things I mean
you're holding on to a dick you just
gotta accept that and keep moving
there's a lot of peopIe yeah you're
right just take the next right action
there's gay people doing [ __ ] that's gay
there's straight people doing [ __ ]
that's gay Oh a jerk that man off once
you commit to that project just keep
going and yes the payoff what do you got
a jerk them off I don't know I don't
think I let me ask you this yeah here's
a question okay if there was a place if
life was free yeah really do whatever
you want if you're a grown adult you
could do whatever you want that's one of
the interesting things about society is
that we set up these rules in cultures
and we decide what you can do and what
we decide is different with the deciding
Hollin is different when they rain yeah
everybody's got different rules yeah but
once we set those rules it's very hard
to buck those rules let's just pretend
there was no rules what if there was a
place where guys would go
and guys would jerk them off and in New
Jersey
like if there was a place where guys
straight guys got a job jerking guys off
hmm
but you it shot you you get paid a
thousand dollars an hour you don't think
that straight guys would take that job
straight struggling guys then you would
they would morph and figure out a way
oh just over a generation or two just a
generation or two if you could make a
thousand dollars an hour beating guys
off yeah start it as I could
that's cheap in each job if you could
wear an oven mitt what you do it I
wouldn't do it just do it
do we figure that uh if you could wear
an oven mitt while you do oh no and oh
no warm oil in your bare skin that's the
only way to jerk eyes off you guys dude
this way other ways man you could
definitely do one way you could do is
even you wrap your heaters do like that
really sideways like a Kentucky Fried
Chicken there's only one batter [ __ ]
nobody likes that crispy batter I'm
trying to think if I had to Jirka one
thing about jerking off to me uh I feel
like there's not as much calm and your
body is there could be you know I'm
saying you don't get that much out well
it depends on what you're jerking off to
and you know how focused you are on the
task if you're jerking off while you're
looking at your phone yeah yeah but you
know you checking your Twitter and your
also beat now you have multi-tap but
you're not gonna get a lot no matter how
much how you do it
really yeah how much do you get you get
like a little bit how much do you get
like if you had a compare it to
something like a quarter no probably
like maybe uh like an eleventh of a
handful I guess I don't know how big is
your hand dude I can't even do you still
masturbate as an adult no I do it as a
job I mean put a diaper rejuvenating
myself
I think you'd rip your dick off yeah
that's true man I uh
I don't know man I actually masturbated
yesterday and I feel bad about it
sometimes but why I decide oh no for
some reason is that's the thing it's a
cultural thing thank God it's when we're
young like think about it this way
what if the culture was all stand-up
comedy culture because arguably stand-up
comedians have a different culture and a
different way of looking at things yes
and it definitely is a good very deep
camaraderie between fellow practitioners
right yeah if that was the culture was
the stand-up comedy culture was the
whole world you wouldn't give a [ __ ] if
you peed off right you wouldn't even be
slightly embarrassed right I tell people
you tell me I tell people where it's at
sure Ari would tell me all the time how
many times be doffed or 200 we all tell
each other how we beat off of what we
beat off - I don't like it as much as I
used to when I was young well that's my
thing you're probably healthier yeah you
know like you gotten older you're more
comfortable you're successful yeah it
just feels like it feels like a novice
move if I'm still jerking off it's 2019
it's certainly a distraction - yeah
something about especially looking at
porn just there's I'm not anti porn I
don't want anybody to get me wrong I
think you should be able to do whatever
you want to do ultimately and I think a
lot of why people have bad opinions
about people doing certain things is
that we judge people when they do
certain things and we have these ideas
about them that we sort of impose on
them right but I think for some people
porn is very useful but you have to have
discipline yeah see the thing is if you
watch porn and you watch two people have
sex and you get excited and you jerk-off
you just took care of like some sexual
needs that you had yeah what could
possibly be wrong with that the only
thing that can be possibly wrong with it
is that there's something wrong with
these two people having sex and filming
it well is there like but doesn't
everybody want to [ __ ] me I don't want
to film myself [ __ ] but doesn't
everybody want to have sex people love
to have sex
obviously one of the most important
motivations that we have oh yeah look
people leave the house every day because
they might have a chance to [ __ ] it's
for sure I mean why do people why do
they get involved
romantic relationships in the first
place to not just not just be nice to
each other but to [ __ ] eventually
sometimes that's the whole thing yeah so
what is it about two people [ __ ] on
film that's so distasteful well you know
you don't want people to see your
special thing maybe or like what you
don't you know you want to keep it
private I get all those gotten too fancy
though it's too high-def though you
can't you're Britney you can real life
can't compete with it so then it's so
it's not always the case this stuff is
just right there but it's not real life
though it's not as good it's not as good
as real life but I think that it's
visually it starts to get that it's
better and it starts to get where like
sometimes I got like I'm 40 days off
pornography right now right really yeah
so you're like on a pornography detox oh
yeah I don't ever want to see it again
really yeah if somebody tries to get
their [ __ ] out I'm like you stopped but
then let me say this to you though you
also had the same kind of issue with
drugs and alcohol right so you have like
an addictive personality yeah that's a
good point so have an addictive
personality you know I was saying
earlier that I think that the thing of
it the thing itself is not necessarily
bad and for some people can actually
provide a service right yeah like it
helps them to jerk off I don't
understand why that would be bad the
only thing they would say is and this is
I don't know how factual this is because
I haven't done any surveys but what I've
read is that a lot of the people that
get involved in that are victims of
abuse mmm that's disturbing right you
don't want to hear that but then some of
them aren't
some of them do it because they want to
do it yeah like isn't that okay that
seems more okay than someone who's doing
it because they're a victim of abuse and
they're desperately seeking love and
attention and they don't know how how to
do it that's a good point so then you
look at it like in terms of but you just
that's looking at that is like well then
don't laugh at comedy right because you
laugh at comedy almost everybody this is
comedians [ __ ] up or [ __ ] over I
mean that's that's really why they get
into it in the first place because they
desperately need attention they want to
be special they want to be something and
they're like look at me look at me so
they figure out how to be funny yeah
usually those are victims of abuse like
it's some way shape or form not all of
them right because they easy
affection they need it they need
something from people maybe six out of
ten right yeah maybe in ambulance hours
yeah yeah so there's so many things that
you could look at that like that but you
know like something good comes out of
stand-up right so we just accept that
that's okay to laugh at these [ __ ] up
people but you know what I mean like
Joey Diaz oh yeah that guy's lived
everything he's seen everything but it's
okay it's okay to laugh at the chaos
that his life was because the jokes are
so funny yeah you know it's it's weird
right but it's not okay to look at like
even if the girls enjoying porn if you
find out that at some point in time she
was molested and that possibly was one
of the motivating factors that led her
into porn then you get super weird about
it yeah you think about it they should
put that on the thing like percentage
chance of somebody that was molested in
the video and I think that that would
deter people from watching a something
so yeah man my thing is just I started
to think of sex then in frames like okay
I got to meet the girl and then we have
to walk over by us so you know we have
to see this and have to see that then
that happens and then now and that's sex
so I started to you know like interpret
it that way and I don't know sex was
just fun when you were young when you
were [ __ ] imagine being 16 and
[ __ ] somebody else it was 16 bro you
know what I want to hear in the
background I'm saying this song living
that died that Diana Ross who sings Oh
Paul McCartney and wings [ __ ]
szura that was from James Bond oh that's
right that's right guns knees oh they
did
that was one time where the [ __ ]
remake is so good that was you kind of
guy wasn't their own song we've been
dancing here some older we hear it has
Axl been on your podcast oh no I
definitely have him on man
Wow I'll definitely have that going on I
can't imagine the brink Yeah right yeah
this who knows what kind of ego happen
and what all happened whenever they went
give me some volume so I couldn't hear
it at least I want to hear him say that
the beginning pass him yeah we go here
we go here we go yeah look out so he was
four years he went crazy yeah vanished
was trying to make that one album
forever right took many many years and
everybody's like goddammit Axl Rose went
crazy I need to see Amy like dan was a
shame Guns N'Roses was so good so good
and then slowly but surely he [ __ ]
came back like really came back like
he's [ __ ] back like that dude tours
with ac/dc now yeah I mean he crushes it
I saw some videos of him on stage he's a
[ __ ] animal again he looks like heart
a little bit like one of them hard buddy
but that's just age in time you know
it's just oh I don't think it's aging
time I think there's a lot of other
ingredients could be shrink throw some
[ __ ] on to that mix well solve us triple
right yeah but you slash looks the same
as last looks the same but that's what
I'm saying they're both the same age
yeah I started out together or close to
the same age at least dude how much fun
must that be [ __ ] decision I think it's
too much fun this is my theory then I
think it's too much fun and I think they
don't even have to write new [ __ ] so
because they don't have to write new
[ __ ] and it's too much fun they're out
there just [ __ ] smashing yeah every
night [ __ ] smashing smashing shows
smashing tour buses and hotel
recognition just smashing each session
[ __ ] they're smashing they probably
crazy you probably even notice if you
[ __ ] a dude if you're that famous I
think you notice I think you're wrong I
beg to differ
oh he's got a hotel
prompter what about a masked dude
there's you know Axl Rose on a
teleprompter desperate but I guess you
want that if you're on all the drugs if
you want all the judge not only do I
want teleprompter I want it to be
highlighted what I'm supposed to say
I mean he's wearing hot pants so close
he's very hot pants with high cowboy
boots with socks ha ha ha and a mesh top
and tighty whities so what is it that
makes somebody so famous that they get
close to being almost like a bisexual
you think do you keep bringing up all
this gay stuff yes you will tell me was
your stepdad right no bro I've never
been gay man never ever no never ever
ever never I mean maybe when I'm 60 or
70 I'll bust out try you know I'll come
on somebody but I'm not doing anything
you know Jay I want a family and
everything I think they're so free with
their expression right that they wear
whatever the [ __ ] they want and I think
that's a part of the culture of really
huge musicians is that they get very
free with the looks their sexuality like
look at him with his mouth with his
ripped up pants Axl Rose back when he's
a cutie-pie
or David Bowie David Bowie when he was
in his androgynous state of prints I
mean you can go on and on and on about
men like [ __ ] Mick Jagger
I mean Mick Jagger would swing his hips
yeah PUF is Leigh Ellis well Elvis is no
stay pretty manly thing but he wore
women's clothing and women's like you
know you know stuff from Mike he wore
stuff from like scarves and shoes
understand know what's that women's
clothing store that's in every like
living secrets no it's for like kind of
more you know Lane Bryant or the big fat
lady stuff he'll shoot a dude clothes
store for fat guys big and tall they
call it yeah but that's like some of
them it's called a g-spot it's over
there on Pico Boulevard J Anthony always
sells those suits over there on stage
what's up oh there he is is that him now
that's him that could be the lady Sheryl
Swoopes no se he's uh that's that's his
Monica hair looks weird like that it's
like he went to spring break
but that's axel from younger days so
that's when he had vanished for a while
right oh but when he did that like he
did a big concert in Brazil too right
and listened to that and his voice was
kind of struggling a little bit cuz he
has such a such a scratchy voice you
know the other thing like that voice
probably very difficult to maintain yeah
but that primal [ __ ] welcome to the
dude that was this [ __ ] when I was that
was like right when I was graduating
high school I remember I worked out this
shitty little gym I'd be on the leg
press machine listen to welcome to that
job what kind of headphones again
whatever they are the big ones though oh
yeah I had a Walkman with a cassette ha
yeah it might have been a disc player
well okay that one's ridiculous that one
makes Oh whose no reason that Holly
Hunter that's him now no it's not Holly
Hunter lead singer I love guns and roses
are you calling my brother nice to beat
each other in our room we'd fistfight in
the yard to [ __ ] Guns and Roses bro
ac/dc it was the music of my childhood
was get was that was GNR Alice in Chains
that's that's a weird look the the the
thermal or the flannel shirt tied around
the waist
what's that look right but that's a
weird look yeah like on purpose
that's a weird look I said Darlene
Connor it's like hey I know I'm not
gonna wear this flannel shirt but I'm
gonna tie it around my waist but hey
it's not really a skirt right it's just
like an accoutrement to my outfit of
fake ripped pants yeah right that's a
weird look isn't it a weird look would
you think you'd rather have like a
little skirt or like be naked you think
skirt oh really
make me self-conscious but what if you
had like a little dick hide or like a
little thing that you could still did
look at how big is your dick either
[Music]
you can't get no escape would you ever
wear a fake dick so that people thought
your dick was bigger if I did it would
be an outrage tuck in the front tucked
in my sock and it would be green like a
holic like a dark green like evilly no
it's fake though feel like how that
guy's is fake bro yeah I think I'm gonna
have dicks in the future it just seems
like everything's going away so fast my
god they're trying to do that with this
new Gillette commercial you seen that
Gillette commercial I heard about that
you can shave your buddy or so No oh
this is really mad cuz it's like an anti
masculine Gillette commercial it makes
like every man look like a misogynist
piece of [ __ ] it's such a disturbing
commercial it's like over and over again
men doing douchey [ __ ] like hey bro
aren't you selling razors yeah changing
the world here shitty [ __ ] advertiser
based philosophy what are you doing like
what are you doing who [ __ ] greenlit
this I know how is that Yelena but like
yo yo yo guys people get hair they want
to [ __ ] shave it just got back do not
get a fix imagine if your of sexist
rapist piece of [ __ ] and you see that
Gillette commercials like damn I'm gonna
switch my game man I've been too much of
a dick like does anybody think the
Gillette commercials are somehow another
in any way shape or form gonna affect
cultures bad you're selling razors is
bad from it's just a razor
I'd rather braid my [ __ ] face hair
than by Gillette nobody wants to be
lectured to we're tired of that so sick
of that stop it you don't have your [ __ ]
together nobody has their [ __ ] together
and you telling people how to get their
[ __ ] together in a [ __ ] razor blade
yeah yeah don't be racist we know don't
be a sexist yeah we know we know most
people aren't yeah this is like you got
it like most people are the videos like
most people are it's not most people are
crazy
that's a disproportionate amount of
people that are that's what I hate about
a lot of the just a lot of these I
the ideology today it's like like they
say everybody where I'm from is racist
or everybody's like you know some
christian bible thumping yeah and it nah
that's not true so many of the people i
know are not that at all that it's
unbelievable but so many of the people
in some and in these other places they
don't even know anybody from there so
it's like they have no idea but they
immediately stereotype because of your
accent - yeah you have a southern accent
people assume you're not bright yeah
it's so stupid but it's also it's
indicative of what the place used to be
like like what the world used to be like
was like a lot of the rural educated
yeah now that there's the internet the
world is a different place man
you can meet cool people in Wichita
Kansas you know cool people everywhere
everywhere you go you're gonna run into
pockets of cool people yeah cool people
are everywhere man
so in people good people are everywhere
and they're they have different values
and a lot of them are more community
oriented more friendly we we on this
side and those on the east side
everybody gets this idea that everybody
is like the people that live all stacked
on top of each other [ __ ] like bees
swarm in the high yeah most people don't
live like that man most people live
somewhere where there's less folks I got
to relax they could throw a frisbee and
not if I can hit anybody that's the most
people you look at the vast majority of
the country there's what is there 300
and how many people billion why does it
350 already
what is it billion million bro million
you're good and billion I'm glad it's
not billion I think there's you
imaginary man I would say 320 if I had
to guess I'd say 320 I'd say it's 325
thank you right but that's like how do
they know about illegals oh who know
it's probably 2 billion if they knew
illegal aliens you wouldn't you be
pissed but how do you know how many of
them what are you doing you counting
them how are they still here dude but
you can't even raise your voice you know
like I have to drive to Riverside even
[ __ ] raise my voice I feel like like
that's how too tight it is in LA 308
million people in the United
Oh in 2010 but that's 2010 mm it was 281
million whoa
look at that dude think about just think
of that 20 [ __ ] million people 28 29
27 million people and who's [ __ ] the
most are they saying is it White's oh
it's all white is it really you think
about [ __ ] every race now bro its new
no I've decided we decided to take back
our country oh no man we're on our way
to white people are on their way to
being a serious minority yeah that's
gonna happen beige power bro that's what
I say everybody I look I love all the
variety but you know what it's like it's
like we have nice things we can't we
can't have nice things we keep breaking
things yeah so we can't what because of
racist people you can't have all this
wonderful diversity so we're eventually
all gonna be gray we're gonna be like
those [ __ ] aliens with the giant
heads and we're gonna have no dicks and
we're all gonna be the exact same thing
so no one can criticize anyone on
anything other than your thoughts and
they're gonna be able to bring your
actions and thinkin be able to read each
other's minds yeah that's what I think
and I think we're gonna ruin the
environment so they have built-in
eyeglasses when you're born they just
[ __ ] glue these [ __ ] on your head
sort of like chicks with fake eyelashes
oh yeah you just you just have these
lenses that you put on when you're
indoors you peel the lenses off and
otherwise you can just see Nate you can
walk outside but you can't really go far
and it's just you see you could press a
fern button in ferns or Papa well just
you know foliage or something you know
fall enough foliage maybe a deer runs by
if you hit that side button I think
nature in the future we'll probably be
contained in these gigantic dome like
places like I'm Stephen King books and
that's where you'll go to get into the
nature yeah like a biodome with Pauly
Shore and Stephen Baldwin I think that's
gonna be like there's gonna be there's
gonna be nature places yeah and the rest
of the world would be City the rest of
the whole plan will be sitting are our
wildlife would be a [ __ ] wildlife
it'll be like you know yeah you a few
thousand acres or something like that of
a bunch of animals living together is
all that's left
it'll be like I can't like a rabbit with
like a little story like a story on its
back
something because if you look at the
population and I'm not one of those doom
and gloom people when it comes to
overpopulation you know why because I
like people on people like yeah there's
too many [ __ ] people you know like I
have good friends to think you know you
want to help the world don't have any
kids Mike okay yeah I get why you would
say that but don't you like people I
love people people are awesome it's all
I know I mean some of them aren't
awesome but the vast majority are pretty
cool yeah or at least capable of being
pretty cool if you're cool to them and
you establish sort of a community being
cool with each other the vast majority
of people are people are nice people are
yeah friendly yes
the vast majority so what's the problem
the problem is was too many of us and
we're not gonna stop right they're gonna
I want to [ __ ] somebody right now you
know we're gonna make people the
question is the will they say stop stop
the study say scientists say that as
people come more affluent and as they
become more educated they're less likely
to have children or they have less
children so they think that the best way
to stop overpopulation is actually
equity in the world like or equality
rather in the world make make the whole
world basically like America where
everybody's just got a chance to get
ahead and everybody has an awesome
education and everybody has access to
the best information it can't happen
but if that does happen that's what's
going to curb overpopulation otherwise
the people that are the least educated
or they're not going to have the same
access to like like in in countries
where people are poorer like for
instance they want to have more kids
because they want the kids to take care
of them too
yes that's a big thing right that's a
big thing in traditional communities and
you know they're tighter and you if you
here's the weird thing if you talk to
scientists they will tell you that
arguably those are happier people yes
happy people that live in these like
villages and stuff and they all enjoy
each other's company even though in our
mind it's a hardscrabble life you know
they're living in a third-world country
in a village but if they have access to
food let's see if they live in the
Amazon or something they have much food
you can get in there you got a lot of
food man like I
know how you would say hey I don't want
to live that way so these people live in
the wrong way they you know they have
[ __ ] ten kids laying on them and [ __ ]
yeah they're all community in this Hut
together and you like that's that looks
terrible for all hot bunks and that
[ __ ] too a lot of times you see the
whole family's in there [ __ ] but
meanwhile those people could be like
really happy yeah they can arguably be
happier than a comparable group of
people in Western civilization that you
would just grab a hundred percent and
why is it black home there's a lot of
black families are still in the woods
you notice that a lot of the tribes
there kind of Darla I guess maybe not
black but it's like a Latino or darker
myth like not I don't know what [ __ ] I
guess it's like a more universal shade
almost kind of like a sofa color well if
you're in the jungle you're obviously in
a hot climate if you're in a hot climate
you better develop some [ __ ] melanin
yeah that's what it is is melon and they
got more melon and family I mean if you
look at it I'm Italian mostly if you
look at it and but I have some Irish in
me too but if you look at Italians
who are in the Sun all the time did they
get darkest [ __ ] yeah you know and if
you were seven seven plus generations of
people living in this one area were you
exposed to like tropical sunlight all
the time oh you had brown the [ __ ] up or
you wouldn't make it
yeah that's true I go to Costa Rica even
for a couple days and I'm [ __ ] you
know browned out of my face is all you
know kind of has pus in it from the Sun
but I think people evolving in a place
like that like being there hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of years maybe
thousands of years like you adapt to
that environment or you you know the the
preferential the preferable jeans are
the ones that make it through yeah and
those people have joy those families
have a lot of joy because they have
their family around you know like if
somebody if somebody dies they have them
right day it's like there's everything's
just a lot more communal I think there's
just a lot more love the only problem is
they don't have like ways to save each
other the way we do right right like
they don't have cars they don't have
modern weapons they have to hunt with
these bows and arrows they make
themselves but they do have pots they
have some things you know but also
depending on what tribe obviously and
also your life expectancy is probably
not as long
if you do die and you believe in a
higher power then you get to go see them
quicker you probably have reincarnation
your you know your friend that died
could now be a plant or a you know
coyote that you meet or something you
know I'm sure in a lot of their cultures
it's a lot of uh you know that just
things are mortis all intertwined you
know human in nature well that was big
with Native American cultures right like
they thought that uh coyotes were I mean
in many different different tribes where
they looked at coyotes almost like they
had some magic to him or something yeah
wise they're up all night I mean I could
see that yeah you're in that tent
sleeping sleeping off that hashish hi
[Laughter]
it's a coyote got trapped in a bathroom
he I want to say it was in South
Carolina or North Carolina they're a
wild man they was in this bathroom and
these guys have to get it out of the
bathroom and sitting on the sink it's
crazy they had to use one of them long
poles that the the jack dogs you know he
grabbed around the neck you see it mmm I
knew was one of those places in
Nashville yeah I could see that dude
it's a cool little video but it's weird
like those little [ __ ] are everywhere
now they are everywhere
well raccoons are really dangerous you
they're always doing you know Jerry is
silent
the Nashville Music Hall and this
beautiful so they're in this hall in a
Boat Show look at him he's chillin it's
a very photogenic
how weird
so what they did was they captured it
and they said that if they brought it to
an animal shelter they would have
euthanized it so instead they captured
it and let it loose in the woods woods
cool do you have any animals that you
don't tell people that you have like any
secret animal I keep a lot of giraffes I
could see you having something now have
you thought about it
oh you start piranhas allegedly and what
do they keep in a tank you know you keep
me in a tank you know you used to be
able to buy a human skeleton online
whose have a human skeleton at the
bottom of my piranha tank really where
does that you buy a skeleton and what
can you do with it I don't think you can
anymore I bet you can't buy them anymore
you used to be able to just buy human
skeleton how long can you keep it the
whole time forever
who was it um here's the funny thing I
got rid of it and we'll get rid of him
like mammal throw away this human
skeleton is some question come with this
you would think it'd be like a Cabbage
Patch doll like it comes with a little
birth certificate we bird it which is
even worse probably and then people are
gonna be like what the [ __ ] someone
someone got killed here yeah someone's
gonna find it someday what the [ __ ] it's
gonna be a giant mystery it sounds fun
I always love mystery man the thing is
somebody might have died like they might
have somebody might have killed somebody
and sold their bones it's probably one
of those are real oh my god what does it
say is that let me look at this a male
from India in good condition 12 teeth
present the rest broken missing there is
lipping on the lumbar vertebra what
but that's $5,000 you could buy a
[ __ ] human skeleton holy [ __ ] dude
there's several of them for sale sale so
the lumbar vertebra lipping you know
what that means I think that means there
his backs [ __ ] up excuse me and what
happens is the discs themselves the
lumbar vertebrae the actual vertebrae
dog bone piece mm-hmm from wearing
against each other it starts to spur and
develop like a curve to the bottom like
I think they're calling that lipping see
if that's what that means whipping
whipping on the lumbar vertebra whipping
whipping on it yeah yeah I got it let's
see that yep that's what it is yeah see
that up image upper left left right
there yeah see how it curves over the
top oh yeah osteoporosis
osteophyte grading or lipping yeah see
as your disc gets smashed your bones
trying to protect themselves and they
grow this extra bone tissue and
sometimes that obviously I'm not a
doctor
and if
you are a doctor stop yelling I know I'm
talking about yeah but sometimes people
that that [ __ ] causes sciatica either
inflamed discs poked out poke into the
nerves or the bone pokes it or it causes
inflammation in the area Eddie Bravo
that he does yeah and he Bravo how that
is uh he got his whole disc replace
without 5s want him disc autumn yeah Wow
yeah he gained an inch in height - did
he really did was back's all [ __ ] up
so like you gotta think like your discs
or these things right these little
things and there's probably a bunch of
them and they bust and when they smash
and get smashed down to nothing I mean
he was basically bone on bone he had
almost no disk so he was in a constant
state of inflammation horrible I need a
text like he couldn't he couldn't sit
down sometimes he'd have to stand up he
would have to hold his lower back and he
does dealt with the pain forever but it
was like almost nothing there so they
replaced so his bones were on top of
each other they replace that and put
this thing they shove it in their
[ __ ] two-story Eddie suddenly he's
talking but and new shirts
yeah he's but he actually is no longer
in pain that's what's amazing yeah and
this is an articulating titanium disc so
they used to have to fuse your vertebrae
together yeah that's what I've heard of
they don't have to do that in every case
anymore sometimes they still do it for
some reasons you know the doctors are
know what they're talking about but for
many people now this articulating
titanium disc is now an option I'm gonna
check it out yeah I know that else is
one surgery part of it taken out how bad
was it was it hurt it hurt bad yeah now
it's better
no it's better now sometimes I have
sciatica though um do you ever stretch
it out yeah do you ever use one of those
teeter inversion tables um no I just got
something free from you guys though in
the lobby what's that thing called pro
formas or whatever oh that's a so right
yeah that's a so us so awesome Asajj
isn't it great so uh yeah that's this
I'm gonna come on that day and think
like a good brother
sorry my thing feels good you are so
horny today I had to drive it's like a
20-minute drive over here drivin nothing
like driving dude no I'll say this
things that get me erect these days
driving being on planes
you know that bumpy roads owners you
Miller real you asked me one time
remember they had a lady I felt like I
got an erection on a plane and she got
pissed she told the she told the flight
attendant to get me a blanket yeah well
did you have it out no a hat was asleep
it was in my pants it was in your pants
yes she saw it somehow yeah
she saw my pants cuz I wear lean pants
lean pants or you know it wasn't wearing
like a like offense canvas or anything
you know textile yeah that's crazy that
she's looking over at your AC though but
I guess if I was a woman and a dude had
a rock-hard boner just like a couple of
feet I would know that's like a ticking
time bomb okay all right but I want a
plane I'm going home yeah but what if
you're a pervert yeah I am a pervert but
I'm still just going home and not using
my dick I mean what kind of scale of a
pervert are you if like ten is jerking
off in front of people on the subway
with a knock that I have a friend that's
a flash for that well you this flashes
and this flash is a jerk off on people
doesn't do that that's that's ten so
then the nine is a flasher that just
pretends to jerk off in front it doesn't
finish yeah or can't get hard and then
you got to go back from there
oh yeah having a softball five what are
you a three no I think I guess perverted
tendencies like what I guess it's like
would is perverted you know well it goes
back to the porn talk like you say that
you had a problem with porn you were
watching too much porn
it became a habit for me that's what I
didn't like it became instead of me
wanting to watch pornography it became
oh I'm used to watching pornography at
night so i'ma do it jerk off and get a
little bit of rest I didn't like the
habit but it created a bad habit well
you uh you get real intense thinking
about things
yeah like even when we're talking about
like business stuff like you can tell
like you get you focus on things yeah
which is good if it's a good thing you
know but sometimes that kind of thinking
can get away from you yeah I think it
does sometimes the same kind of focus
that can get you
really excited about something that's
productive in your life can also get you
obsessed with something that's not
productive
it's a set the kind of person that you
are in a lot of performers you're an
impulsive creative person impulsive
creative people sometimes get caught in
ruts you know and there's a bunch of
different reasons I think for for
addictions
I think there's psychological addictions
physical addictions some of them are
undeniable like physical addictions some
of them will kill you like you get off
of alcohol too quick you'll die
yeah it's a physical addiction that is
real at a point you can't pretend it's
not real that shit'll kill you right so
it's obviously real but then there's
other ones like washing your hands too
many times like some people are addicted
to washing their hands I know what dude
it doesn't go anywhere without Purell
everywhere watching his hands it's
putting pressure on that's crazy I just
like to touch doorknobs put touches
doorknob Purell back to the hands it's
weird
and you [ __ ] up your skin flora like
it's not good yeah we had a dude they
used to lick both of his shoulders for
it start talking me oh that's good
it was crazy that's Alette [ __ ]
know you're serious oh yeah that's that
Irish hello right we're in crazy town
you're the mayor lucky dude you licked
your shoulders until we had a tea we had
to do in our town he put like a
chocolate on your shoulder you try to
get it off get it off that's not right
that guy's gonna grab you one day and
[ __ ] you well he did you in trouble or
something I don't remember what it was
I'd grown up but he was he's like one of
those angler fish he's tricking you
yeah he's getting you to look at that
huh he's gonna get you I come looking
for that chocolate guy yeah you know my
shoulder book he looked down he's got a
bat in his hands well if you did it's
like you on that plane go get you
chocolate chocolate but here's the main
man
what here's the thing is if you put
Stevie Wonder move you just did huh just
kind of get my neck better I'm trying to
get my neck longer everyone wearing a
little bit of a neck brace sometimes
it's not stretching it out it's just
tight my neck feels kind of or not tight
it feels short yeah have you used those
things the harness that goes on under
the chin and you attach it to the top of
the door and you pull on it quickly
I've seen this those are great really
yeah yeah yeah if you have a tense neck
I'm a big believer in that kind of
spinal decompression yes there's want
that yeah you can get that and I got a
really good one out here two two really
good ones from that Teeter company we
you put your waist on one of them and
you lean forward and it stretches your
lower back and the other one you hang
from your ankles it's really good for it
feels good to it'll leave you cuz it's
just like that compression of life sick
of it yeah smashing you down and it's
very rare that you do anything that like
I have a terrible problem slumping I've
always slumped I've always been like
I've always had [ __ ] posture for
whatever reason it's not good like
you're supposed to sit up straight yeah
you know you're supposed to your back is
supposed to be straight so you can be
like I sometimes I like I sit like this
yeah I'll talk to people be like that
like my head is forward it's like just
very bad for your back like you're
making your your disks carry your weight
in an uneven way what you want to do is
have everything everything up and strong
obviously this is exaggerated but most
people like you get lazy so what well
what good posture is is like a constant
state of exercise that's what good
posture is yes I'll just slump all the
time but yeah but doing posture all the
time it feels like you're always like
you know about to graduate you know I
feel like you always have to be like
kind of like don't say that it's like
but you don't have to be exaggerated but
you really should and I've been trying
over the last few years really hard to
do that
just straight I need to get an alarm for
my spine that's it that's the [ __ ] I
love that's called the the teeter Dex
inversion that's one of my favorite
things ever for loosening up your lower
back really decompressing you yeah I got
one right here man and it's not
prohibitively expensive either I'll hop
on that before I leave
yeah that thing right there
when you go down when when it uh press
play so you can see how it works you
hang down like that and when you hang
down like that it just lengthens
everything and straightens it out and
that's the one where you hang by your
ankles I love that one too all the ways
yeah it looks good right I cannot even
imagine they have that good for you I
got one right here but really I feel
like something you would do to kill a
deer or something
no that's that's a different kind of
thing man that's wild man I need some
stuff I think I need to get more you
know bars and stuff I could hang off of
I got to alleviate some pressure for
your shoulders like chin-up bars grab
ahold of a chin-up bar just hang hanging
is really good for your shoulders
because everything gets compacted
everything gets like punched in and
nothing stretches out I'm built like a
Conestoga wagon brother you know that
and still going Conestoga what does the
Conestoga it's like a wheel base is
really question was like 6x6 you know
like I'm not that [ __ ] you don't move
that good I mean I think I used to be
able to but I got it going to the past
bro you're still young enough to move
like that right now yeah another thing
that's a Conestoga wagons built like
that imagine if you just decided that's
how you're gonna rock it from now on
you're on the highway people are beeping
at you get your motor running wooden
wheels wagon dragging behind your Ram
pickup truck a [ __ ] a bar of gold
just falls out the man you got a
Silverado Chevy Silverado pulling a
[ __ ] covered wagon baby like you
can't do that why not cars registered
yeah it's all legal who the [ __ ] is
buying wagons these days people buying
them today
oh the wagons coming back it's just
these [ __ ] that want to reenact a
civil war and pretend they're still
slavery well here's the thing bro I
understand re-enacting it in the winter
but they do it in the summer man do they
really yeah you don't want to do in the
winter you'll die and the South always
wins the reenactment too it's just wild
no it doesn't really yeah I don't mean
so real I think there's a little bit of
you know what they should do they should
reenact the Civil War and kill
themselves
not in real life but in the in the fake
what you mean pretend hey man I want to
fight for slavery and just all pretend
to kill themselves yeah
oh that's interesting yeah they should
say hey we're gonna we're gonna do it
the right way or we're gonna toss down
our guns and suck all the dicks of the
guys in the North yeah well then they
would won that one if they decide that
they don't what if they're like if they
catch us they're sucking dicks like it
has to need the nutrients they're
starving dude I was thinking about this
do you think that so slavery right they
had it do you think that what if I had
this thought of one day what if
computers artificial intelligence
happens ok takes over and then they're
all gonna know that we had we owned
these phones yeah yeah just like people
soon like they were slain like this was
a slave like remember when you owned my
little buddy emotional about that I see
where you going with that but I disagree
I don't think that'll be an actual
factor I don't know I got the rose gold
one that undo nothing like that but you
got a black case on it that's ridiculous
yeah that's true if you go in rose gold
I think you have to go caseless like a
I'm not going caseless man a lot of
people go Kate look at Jamie caseless
are you really James a caseless
barbarian wow I bet he jerks off for
this [ __ ] his natural hand that's
nice huh adorable
do you see your kids every day yeah
sometimes I keep my eyes closed
[Laughter]
is it nerd Dave were you nervous at
first to have them yes yeah nervous to
be vulnerable nervous to love something
that much nervous to have that kind of
responsibility nervous about all those
things yeah that you changes you changes
you like nothing else but did you feel
like the changes would be for like that
you won't like the changes and then you
did like I'm like did you have
reservations well I didn't
have a relationship with my father
growing up so for me it's very it was
very very important that I did whatever
I had to do to have a relationship with
them to be as present as I can be to
like to whatever whoever I was before
had them to evolve to mean to get better
like it's it's it's a very when you have
kids it's a very weird thing what
happens to you because all of a sudden
it's you're not alone anymore oh yeah
you like you you don't just have
responsibilities like you have a dog you
have to feed or a plant you have a
little person yeah and you don't want to
[ __ ] up that little person you like [ __ ]
and it feels overwhelming and then the
world feels so dangerous change the view
of the world though yeah there's so much
threat there's so much out there that
could stop signs planes stories - you
read stories about terrible people and
terrible things that happen oh and then
you're like [ __ ] it I don't have to
worry about this just happened to me
after wherever this happen to know
somebody else - and your little song you
know yeah that's wild brah that's crazy
world in you you think of people
differently because you think of people
as a project that developed instead of
being in a static state that's
interesting did you did did do you think
that something like emotionally happens
to you like at a level that or a DNA
level yeah yeah the love you had like
Dave Chappelle said this best goes not
only to do increase my love it increased
my capacity for love that's a great way
of putting it
I would I would agree 100 percent
increases your capacity and you become
at least me I became a nicer person I've
seen it not work - I've seen people that
just reject it I've seen men and women
that just don't want to be parents
yeah I've seen women move away from
their kids they don't want to take care
of their kids I've seen men abandon
their families they just don't want to
do it it's crazy and I don't know if
it's a mental health issue or if it's
just some people just can't take it
yeah Everett like there's like attitudes
and this is not just about raising
children's about pretty much anything
difficult in life
there's some people that have a very low
quit point very low they just quit
everything they quit it gets tough quit
quit there's a lot of people that just
quit and when you have a little like say
if you have a little Theo in front of
you and you think about your life and
your childhood and like how important it
is for you to raise this little person
and give them love and teach them about
life and protect him become safe and
give them good lessons in life yeah it
just changes everything man changes
everything changes everything
but it also is very ver whelming it's
over well it's eerie Assange xiety when
they have kids they start thinking about
the responsibility and the weight of it
all or they don't some people just
[ __ ] take pills and lay on the couch
and let their kids suck [ __ ] carpet
glass and [ __ ] stick Forks into the
wall sockets and you play with knives
people just don't some people don't give
a [ __ ]
some people are dumb that's that's the
thing two men died you know people don't
want to say this but there's folks out
there they just aren't equipped for life
I really believe that I think D come the
dumb brother that's what I'm saying take
the semen out of them you know I'm
saying like at a certain point but
here's the problem you're dumb compared
to physicist so who's the who's to judge
and who's to say that this person is
really stupid couldn't have a brilliant
child that happens to men a lot of times
brilliant people come out of state
adversity man who knows what they need
but it's like it's not our job to decide
who's stupid and who's not because it
gets slippery oh yeah you you could get
box into that stupid corner in a
different metric if you're hanging
around with a bunch of people from
Stanford you know and they're looking
steel Vaughn's the neighborhood and they
know there's 10 people the neighborhood
but only nine can survive it's like
resources for nine we're gonna get rid
of me probably depends on how good you
are at digging ditches oh it could be
better than them at that though yeah so
suddenly I have a different skill I
don't know it's have you thought about
having kids yeah I think about it a lot
more like as I get a little bit older I
just yeah the thing for me is just like
about being brave I think and just being
willing to have my life just be totally
different and be a
with that no and just being like willing
to know that I would be okay in that
space you know I think it's hard it's
like I just it's like I'm just starting
to manage the space that I'm in like I
just has a regular person and then to
get to that point where now it's like
[ __ ] you have another ball you have two
balls in the air you know wife and a kid
or yeah and then what we're talking
about earlier look sometimes people [ __ ]
people that they don't really like to
hang out with yeah I'm not doing that
anymore man that's where it gets
slippery because sometimes that sex is
fun man I was just talking to a buddy of
mine about this he's got a guy he's a
single guy and he's got a gal that he
[ __ ] every now and again they get
together and they both kind of know what
it is yeah
he gets it together and they work one
out and then they see yeah that's it and
his his take on it is interesting he's
like you know and some people you just
don't want to seem that often like
that's okay
that's okay but the problem is it's not
always Mutual mmm right sometimes the
guy wants to see the girl more than she
wants to see him or vice versa and then
they becomes some weird thing one person
starts talking the other person's
Facebook yeah you know people start
getting weird with people you know like
that's that's actually an addiction to
people get addicted to each other just
as much as they get addicted to
pornography just as much they get
addicted to wash their hands or anything
else people absolutely get addicted to
certain people
oh yeah well then that person doesn't
wanna have sex with you anymore like
it's like they're taking away your drugs
you know and really dumb men and in
those cases get very dangerous because
because yeah they start thinking this
person's done something to them because
they don't want to be with them anymore
and really dumb men are dangerous right
there yeah that's where you know you you
you hear about women getting stalked by
their exes and murdered and that's where
that [ __ ] comes I hate that really dumb
men who are angry now that the person
that they loved doesn't want to be
around them anymore
yeah and they can't look at themselves
and they're probably mentally ill and
they might be on medication who the [ __ ]
knows what trifecta or what
conglomeration of factors is making them
be that piece of [ __ ] but yeah they just
feel a I want you via people man get
feeling they get they feel rejected and
then you just wanna ya you don't know
what to do sometimes you get addicted to
somebody else's love or lust or sad
all those things yeah women - men - I
was talking to a gal who was going
through this with another gal couple of
lesbians couple of lesbians field
talking about boy less one lesbian was
mean to the other lesbian apparently I
was delivering a furniture you know what
I'm sayin boy domestic abuse there was
some article about domestic abuse
growing and lesbian communities yeah
yeah
it's disturbing it's a dark arts man and
those women are and some of those women
are tough you think tough as nails
would you fight a lesbian for an
undisclosed amount of money yeah really
you don't even have to hear the number
what is undisclosed man do I get to hear
at all no I'm not can i train first I
wouldn't like Amanda Nunez I wouldn't
let you phone no no no no yeah it has to
be a woman at least I've seen a couple
pictures of them you know like I just
want to be able to make sure yeah I've
seen like a couple of images of him or
at least be able to scroll through their
instant you see that video of that grown
man who punched that 11-year old girl in
the face of the mall that [ __ ] makes me
mad yeah he's so crazy
there's a bunch of kids apparently then
we're involved in some sort of a scuffle
this guy comes over to break it up he's
yelling at them break it up break it up
one kid pushes him and then he says
something and then pushes the girl she
goes flying she's a little tiny person
he's a big dude she comes at him with
her dukes up and he just [ __ ] way
laser I didn't see the hits her with a
straight left right in the mug he's a
big grown man like he looks like a big
man who knows how to throw a punch I'm
not gonna play the video you want to
find it go fine no I don't want to see
it [ __ ] disturbing but two things you
should tell you one that guy definitely
shouldn't have done that but - she
shouldn't have [ __ ] run at that big
giant man with her dukes up yeah like
God I know she's 11
I get it she didn't know she's a kid and
sat down teach kids and some 11 kids are
hearty some 11-year olds are hot I like
what if you get her like I knew a 12
year old that's no no she's this big oh
she's little she's tiny
she's like nipple high on him Oh
ko sir you want to see it No
you do you do want to draw it for me on
a napkin I don't want to see it yeah
those are the old days man YUM do we
have a guy remember they had a guy who
sold some tits into armed man a pint you
maybe a birch or something and people
would go out there and go jerk off at
the base of the tree he I think use like
a stepstool or something versus a barrel
that's when you found all the magazines
in the woods Oh at least have that but
times you go out on the tree and
somebody will be using the tree like oh
[ __ ] I've got a walk back home that's
not real you're making this up you have
photographs this tree No why not do you
know where it is
could you take us back there with the
film crew okay thank you back here oh I
bet it did I bet it devolved now though
but always a tree live go back there and
touch the thing and all sudden you can't
find your way back we're going in a
circle like it turns out that the tree
got tired of people jerking off on it so
it involves some sort of a neurotoxic
Apple then when you touched it it got in
your bloodstream and distorted your
perception of distance and time yeah but
do what if you would have come could
divide they what if semen could defy
gravity what do you think about that I
don't but you know I do think imagine if
it wasn't if come didn't just get humans
pregnant
yeah oh that's what I think of some
frogs the chickens
I give everywhere you went you found guy
just dude [ __ ] a turtle you followed
some turtle person you gotta [ __ ] you
can't think about that man
imagine if anything could get anything
pregnant yeah a new combination was born
turtle people - that's what's next
koi people some - [ __ ] - koi yeah bustin
is that cool calm knock that coin
imagine you're out there throwing bread
on your koi pond okay it has legs what
the [ __ ] man somebody [ __ ] one each
people sleep on the shore it's got a
sign for you quite people a tattoo
people see you people see what the pet
store shopping and they're like whoa
this guy's shady imagine if Ari [ __ ]
it and it came out and we knew it
because that Ari's knows yeah so it's
like Ari's nose on a koi fish with legs
and it comes out Ari would your business
a little Bali
do you imagine yeah I'm gonna go find my
my turtle babies in the other side of
the world but if you had to make love to
an animal what would it be if you think
you had to go in there something I could
brag about yeah I'm not [ __ ] anything
sedentary I'm not [ __ ] anything
that's like a basic something's up in
the poultry section or anything like
that no beef it have to be a female what
if you had gay sex with an animal which
animal would it be that's not gay -
[ __ ] animal bro it's not I don't
think that applies dude you're [ __ ]
an animal that's more both if it's a
like a male gorilla I think it's both
haha dude okay gay and bestiality nobody
seemed to be like oh man would mean
they're gonna go not only did he [ __ ] a
chip he [ __ ] a male champ and
everybody be like Jesus vo bro you would
never buy a beer again you put you want
to break the internet you put a [ __ ]
video and me sneaking up on a cheetah
yeah and [ __ ] it well gavel rapping a
noose around its neck and you're banging
it while it's clawing on ya
trying to get away and you nut no I'm
talking about putting on some just Eddie
Levert or some gerald levert and playing
some sweet music into something like
that how you plan on holding it in place
while it's all happening I think if
you're good enough and gentle enough
it'll stay you don't think so think
about it you for a telling it though I
love to look at the world through your
eyes whatever medication we're on we got
to change it we gotta fix it
bro you should meet yourself then bro
you are extraterrestrial man
that's the most I smiled all week
they're so good oh dude we always have a
good time bro
that's funny are you working tonight you
doing triple e shows yeah you are yeah
yeah yeah that's fine those are good
times dude what a fun job man I just
started realizing it this year that's
what I'm saying like your idea of like
looking back on your youth are you crazy
we're alive we're alive doing the most
fun job you could have yeah how do we
change that you only get busy I'm gonna
like you know get busy living this year
and just try more things and just you
know enjoy my time that I'm not diet
that I am alive that's what's up
I really do the whole thing about life
is all that I wish I was doing this I
wish I was doing that is only good if
you're working toward something but I
wish I was young again let that go that
is not happening
yeah I wish I was eight foot tall that's
not happening I wish I could fly nah nah
I wish I could breathe underwater like
oh man it's not happening I could see
not gonna get gills installed bo I could
see you coming up one day they don't
come up with some gene-editing some
gills oh yeah man [ __ ] scuba dive Joe
takes you to the side and shows you his
gills
I don't like snorkeling bro yeah a
little bit when I was in Hawaii it's fun
yeah man
it's wild you're out there looking down
you watched all these fish swimming
around like that we went near this coral
reef it's crazy it's just this world
down there where the puss and how easy
it was it for you to block out like
sharks or something just not a blue not
easy
no no that's real like you're always
thinking like what if one of those
[ __ ] is here oh and you look
like a dealt like a damn delectable
event to a shark but yeah I mean you
don't say if you did if Joe's out there
that's a that's a real snack how many
famous people have been killed by sharks
that ever happened that'd be crazy
I feel like LL Cool J got killed by a
shark and Malibu like what how is that
real how could it happen
right what if AJ Simpson got jacked by a
shark can you imagine how many haha'
would break out across the country yeah
ah if you could see Oh Jay Simpson in
flute have to be Florida he'd be he's in
Florida a lot of white trash girl oh
[ __ ]
he's waving waving to the beach and you
see the fin like 15 feet away from him
if you go under and then no way oh dude
I bet Oh Jay Simpson and Dennis Rodman
have [ __ ] a lot of the same chicks bro
when you think about that with what if
the kid well I don't think OJ Simpson's
allowed to leave the country right-o
saying what if Kim Jong Un's starts
partying with OJ ha ha ha it's a good
like I don't care the juice is loose
dude a buddy of mine was doing cocaine
with OJ Simpson one time and you and I
in Miami how long this is like 15 years
ago post murder then yep after the
murder and the guy goes hey does anybody
have a car key and then he hits OJ's
okay you have a car key or a knife
that's what he asked him for to do the
cocaine off of oh no she's like this
guy's got a [ __ ] knife
was he laughing yeah oh my that's pretty
funny
I think it's funny I mean if you didn't
get in trouble for it even if you did it
I think having a sense of humor about it
still important the way he reacted every
step of the way did not seem like a guy
was being accused of something he didn't
do every step anyway every step of the
way I wouldn't do that yeah I couldn't
do that
I don't even a man that is not what
you'd say yeah if your wife got killed
right he would not be thinking like that
you'd be - freaking the [ __ ] out but you
should watch this witness Nolte no it's
so Sasha Baron Cohen and the very very
end of the show is almost like a bonus
scene oh I didn't know he got this deep
with the outfit who's the gal it's just
it's part of this is like cell she's
like a girl that's supposed to be with
him he's like this extravagant
millionaire billionaire type character
oh and he's got a Jay yeah I need to see
this show period I think he spent like
three or four hours with him he said did
you hear that they might have uncovered
a pedo ring
he might have uncovered a pedo ring when
he was doing this Oh Jaden no Sasha
Baron Cohen oh wow oh yeah did you see
it read the headline that says if you
find with the exact specifics of it were
but like they decided not to air it but
it's like what dude you know what when
you said that about OJ it made me think
I met Buzz Aldrin from the moon yes and
he's and when I met him it didn't seem
like he'd been to the moon
yeah scent cut who is America interview
to FBI over fears of Las Vegas pedophile
around whoa said the goat
said the interview led him to believe
there could be a pedophile ring in Las
Vegas holy [ __ ]
could you imagine if a pedophile ring in
Las Vegas was exposed by Sacha Baron
Cohen in a comedy movie and they find
out it's real I wonder if this is all
just a setup for some other type of film
but let's look at it objective okay okay
there has to have been pedophile rings
in the past undeniably I would think if
you go back you go back to like the 50s
or the 40s or the 30s there has to be
something like that way easy-bake yeah
they take orphans and they molest them
all that Sandusky type [ __ ] that has
been going on yeah so how often has it
been going on and what happens now to
the same type of people like if that's
no longer available for them is there
some way they get it some super [ __ ]
super tightly watched circuit ring of
people who still engage in this activity
and figured out a way to do it I hope
not
I hope not to everybody hopes not but
the idea that it's impossible the idea
that it's impossible is unlikely yeah
there's probably a market for it sadly
well you think about it all the time
when you think about other countries
right oh yeah they're doing it they're
for sure yeah most of our guys it seems
fly over these other countries and be
dirty over there yeah going over there
and there's a ring a pedophile ring oh
that's scary dude who wants to [ __ ] some
kid
that's crazy I think they think it's
mostly people who have been abused like
that themselves yeah mostly yeah that's
one of the things that Kevin Spacey's
brother is said about Kevin is that
Kevin is basically like their dad and
their their dad sexually abused them and
now Kevin is acting that out and there
was an interview his dad his brother
rather Kevin see Kevin Spacey's brother
mine everybody looks like Rod Stewart on
the strongest acid available who he's
crazy-looking missus weird-looking guy
with wacky hair and he wears funky
glasses and weird clothes Donnie what's
his name I don't know what his name is
he looks like he's wearing a costume
Donnie Spacey that's not it is it no mmm
but here take a look at him jeez look at
this that's that's his brother ha ha
dang it looks like nice castle guy an
English scientist and Rod Stewart I
can't believe Kevin the one they got
banged by the dead I think they both did
I think he's saying they both did I
can't believe I even uh said that it's
messed up yeah that's sad man they said
their dad was a monster yeah yeah look
at his dad like look look at his brother
how he dresses up look at that crazy Rod
Stewart outfit yeah I bet like one chick
or one dude [ __ ] him because I thought
it was Rod Stewart it's like look I'm
just gonna ride this ride Stewart huh
this is outfit that's crazy outfit that
is a crazy crazy outfit he's got rings
on every finger he's got a wallet chain
across his pecker Wow those dicks
keeping time brother yeah look at that
shirt that fluffy shirt with the
crazy-ass neck accoutrements yeah if
you're not trying to get [ __ ] by
somebody you shouldn't wear all this huh
yeah and but but think about how much
effort it took to do all this now go up
to his teeth son yeah son what's up that
mug at Scotland bro clean that [ __ ] up
is he from Scotland it's Kevin Spacey
from Scotland I think they're from
Britain I think they're from America
really yeah weird where was Kevin Spacey
born [ __ ] if you know you're googling
yeah well yeah you know you're right the
Google in front of you um but no doubt
the what about this do you think he
would have been as talented if he didn't
have this affliction
where does it say this is any worries
from orange teachers you see there you
go perfect dump and one of most talented
men of our time I think people in New
Jersey [ __ ] you bro hey I was born there
he is very talented he's also very crazy
and I think in his day you could get
away with a lot if you had a movie star
I think you know they just they ran
those sets like uh yeah they're crazy
well they have that are Kelly thing now
I mean that huh guy his whole life he
got to do what everyone at it seemed
like that's a different animal right
because he's a musician but yeah it
seems like he's the underage the
underage thing with him is Lea married
Lea underage had sex with her underage
and it was told armor we just grew up
listening to his music it was choice
girls are coming out about him doing
that to them when they're yeah but a lot
of people knew thirty fourteen they're
saying 15 well I can't believe more
people on comes let's see there was a
video you know that weren't complicit in
that oh is unbelievable what about the
people that like well here's what's
crazy did the video is out of him peeing
on people and then years later people
are still making music with them yeah
wow that's crazy that's crazy yeah
that's crazy
when you find out how many people were
what was it was it The Breakfast Club
what show was it that they they started
reading off a list of all the people
that worked with our Kelly mmm-hmm post
video so the video was out Lady gaga all
these people and like a giant number of
people do you think we'll ever be able
to eradicate that the fact that people
do that to like have like the pedophile
or have that vibe for them first the to
sexual sexualized children or young
people hopefully scientists will figure
out a way to isolate that part of human
thinking someday like hopefully there'll
be something
researchers doctors scientists
psychologists whoever it is figure out a
way to stop that but in the meantime
what it has gotten is way more difficult
for them to get away with it
right right and it is going to get more
difficult still
I think people are going to be connected
I mean we're connected right now with
cell phones mm-hmm like this is how
weird the connection is you know Adam
Greentree who was here yesterday we just
we were talking about Toyota Tundras he
said after we were talking about it he
said all of his ads on his phone like
when he would look at a website it would
all be Toyota ads no way it's like
they're listening yeah they're listening
to his phone like the word Toyota Tundra
came up over and over and over again in
his search searches Toyota trucks
because we see that Hans Toyota trucks
Toyota trucks I'm gonna say that and put
a draw
Toyota Tacoma say it over and over again
yeah but whatever the [ __ ] process of I
mean I don't know if he actually
accidentally googled Toyota trucks that
day - yeah but they found out he's their
kid my point is like saying something in
a conversation and it's being connected
to these internet searches like these
little things are starting to happen and
it's gonna get more and more prevalent
it's over for us we're gonna be like way
more connected now then we're gonna be
way more connected rather in 10 years
and we are now look man we got to figure
out what would that be like because no
one saw this coming yeah no one saw us
being disconnected so what the [ __ ] is
it going to be like if we're connected
much much more than that in the future
what's that gonna be it's gonna be it's
gonna be something unimaginable because
it's this was unimaginable right so
that's what I'm thinking it's going to
be some next plane that we're gonna get
to there has to be some next level of
intuition maybe that comes into it or
yeah I when I was really high I thought
this up yeah my really high thought was
you know how kids learn things really
easily
they learn things way easier they can
learn a language really easy they're
gonna if very soon in the future a
universal language is developed that
coincides with artificial artificial
intelligence technology virtual reality
and augmented and augmented reality and
so this universal language allows people
of all languages they can learn it and
they can learn it and this was coming
off with something that Jamie said once
we were talking about emojis being
almost like hieroglyphs like wow like
that seems so weird because they seem so
cute and corny but but someone could
send you a whole like series of them
like eggplant water smiley face
high-five in and that's like Oh
someone's a [ __ ] oh yeah that's my right
meet time to meme a picture could sell
sure well while I was thinking that I
was like okay well what would stop once
they develop augmented reality or
artificial reality in some sort of a
easily digestible form whatever it is
whether it's a chip that you have in
your body that sends signals directly to
your brain allows you to communicate
with each other if we developed a
language and we can send and receive
images in a way that may be even more
effective than the language that like we
assume that English is the best way to
talk because we only know how to talk
English right maybe if we could speak
Chinese we could express ourselves clear
maybe we we speak Turkish or Arabic
maybe there's a better one I don't know
I only like one language but what if
sound languages are far inferior to
visual languages and what if these
visual languages allow people that even
can't even see to see because they could
send it directly into their mind they
can see these things with their eyes
closed they're not even using their
eyeballs and everybody can communicate
on an even plane so there's no language
barriers hmm and what I was thinking
this almost like well that's Covey's
isn't possible no it's not impossible
because there's all more than a hundred
languages I mean how many languages are
there if you had to guess I would bet
there's probably 100 and maybe 15 yeah I
bet you're right I'll say 130 let's go
crazy
I'll see 130 level cast it's probably a
thousand who the [ __ ] knows one language
Bob one language Bob more more than a
thousand okay I'm gonna go then me I
would like to have a separate guest I
want to go with 1800 I would like to go
with 1060 mmm that says there are
roughly this is number of spoken
languages in the world today 6,500 whoa
what where how about sure about about
2000 of those have less have fewer than
a thousand speakers so even if we count
those off it's still 4 over 4
well you know those people on that
Sentinel North Sentinel island I think
they have a dead language there's only
3000 really where that guy got killed
there's only 39 of them 4000 so even if
you take up that 2500 right if you take
those off the ones that he said that
only less than a hundred people are yeah
but they're using it right good point
well here's the thing that's really
crazy um the the the indigenous people
of Australia my friend Alan green tree
who's here yesterday he he works with a
lot of these people he is a like a
mining company and one of his like a
bunch of the people that I work with
would explain to him these different
languages that they're not written down
and you and your mob like they would
call the Aborigines who call themselves
like it's it's not like a clan it's
called a mob they're a term for it would
have a totally different language and
someone who lives just a few miles away
so they'd be a different mob it was a
few miles away totally different
language you can't understand what the
[ __ ] they're saying they don't know what
the [ __ ] you're saying then there's
another one over here and there's never
one the one I'm like how many do you
think there is he's like I was probably
hundreds well like hundreds hundreds of
different languages nobody knows what
the [ __ ] anybody say it's almost like
they don't want the other one to know
because it's like they'll get their
secrets maybe how many do you think
there's another report that says there's
this number of languages that are spoken
in US homes as of this as of 2015
okay a smaller number but 300 350 Wow at
least it says at least three if you had
asked me before this conversation always
said 13 yeah me too I was gonna guess
actually I was gonna guess I'll laughing
[ __ ] that's a lot of languages dang
that's so crazy
foster's we're at [ __ ] no no we're okay
that makes my point I think the next
stage is a universal language yeah
universal language would like think
about the Aborigines there that's how
[ __ ] up situation to be in nobody
knows what the [ __ ] anybody saying and
none of those things are written down so
you have to be in that clan to
understand that language or that mob and
then they die off and yeah they're not
yeah their thing in small small ball
well they didn't think it's not planned
out well but we are connected everyone's
interconnected and I think through a
universal language it's entirely
possible
we could reshape civilization yeah
through a universal language that every
kid picks up in school you teach them
bing-bong right up side English or
Chinese or anything else but Bing bong
is the the the Internet latter route and
this internet language that everybody
understands everybody just starts
communicating through Bing bong and
nobody yeah nobody's using regular
language anymore you just occasionally
talked like when you're in bed you talk
ya [ __ ] you remember dirty talk yeah
English talk vile or French dirty talk
there's a hundred and eighty five s that
are spoken just in Los Angeles but that
makes sense if there's 300 in the
country I would think all of them would
be here I'm more shocked that all money
is pretty multicultural area there's a
group in twenty five hundred people or
so that speak Dutch at home and
Riverside oh yeah that makes sense
but only Dutch not egg well not only but
that mostly maybe I get when the lights
Riverside Dutch are so aerodynamic they
move good you know you ever seen a Dutch
that really are dynamic they're the what
what are you doing your lean face lean
headed four inches cheek to cheek or big
people
dude dude how big they're the Dodge Howe
they're very tall but they're very
aerodynamic very aerodynamic the
downhill people they call him dude look
at pull up a Dutch okay pull up arnesto
who's yeah
Ernesto let's get a gander at this fella
right here miss Dutch kickboxer mr.
perfect I bet you it's hard to kick him
on the sides of his heads because he's a
little less than others it's goddamn
with Donais okay that's him later in his
career too if you get earlier in his
career he's more jacked get earlier in
his career win it right there BAM take
that picture right there no no the one
above it where your cursor was to right
to the right to the left of that one or
right I'm sorry of that photo you just
pulled up the right of the photo you
just pulled up that one right there BAM
that's what he looked like when he was
in his prime
let's get a phasic Dutch that guy's in
advance though I feel like advance Dutch
look at him yeah that guy's okay how
about Rob came in our OB kam n ra n
rather
while the greatest kick boxers of all
time and there we go aerodynamic yeah it
come narrow as head is what I was
looking at your sideways
what up about basic Dutch God does not
look like a guy with a narrow head bro
yes it doesn't mind ah ah her head was
next to his head
you you you his head would eclipse your
head no yes it would
there'd be nothing behind you look how
long that hit is narrow his head got in
front of you I wouldn't even know you
that I do is that you back there I'd see
the bottom like I I'm back here jerking
off with my not it doesn't count did I
you think it's better be crazy in this I
don't want thing about this but to watch
people from different ethnicities jerk
off you know we're back to this again
but you know what I'm saying though cuz
everybody probably you should watch a
little from memory now uh yeah I'm
jerking off from memory now do you find
that your fantasies become more
elaborate a hundred percent they're more
exciting it up no set it up in your head
oh no it's so how many days a week he
beaten it more than four and you got a
pro no two days a week and I'm
disappointed at that I'm just trying to
turn over a new leaf you know I want to
not jerk off yeah I'll be confused I
think that's uh that's look there's a
read there's a if you just look at
sexual desire and lust yeah there's a
reason why you become more and more
desperate as time goes on it's like your
your sights are set too high or you're
not being ambitious enough you got to
spread your seed if you think about how
ridiculous it is if people didn't know
that having sex with people has
consequences and and by that I mean you
can get pregnant you can get diseases if
there was no end of this cultural
limitations people frown upon it but if
there's none of those and imagine how
much people would be [ __ ] oh yeah it
would be insane
yeah if there was no such thing as
masturbating he could [ __ ] at a gas
station pee wee [ __ ] yeah if there's
no such mastery Batian wasn't possible
first of all you know what would happen
what women would rule everything 100%
because man would have so much chi built
up in them nope nope they're [ __ ]
they'd be given in every chance they go
cuz the women would unit it would be
worth so much more
yeah because women would be able to
decide whether or not you came there's
only way that was the only way if women
were the rulers yeah whether or not you
came if there was no way to come without
them oh my god they would dominate we're
[ __ ] dude I know that the next law if
they're really smart that's how they
would take over chop our arms off dude
you telling me though you wouldn't watch
like a little like Chinese guy jerk off
from like 30 feet away go back to this
again
no but just tell me much train accidents
I don't want them to happen Jamie pulls
up a video of a train accident all my
god you gotta see this watch it okay go
ahead okay i watch it
oh I don't watch that kind of stuff you
know but tell me about this how close do
you get like there's a Chinese got
jerking off in a park okay
and he's ma he's depends on Who I am
he's Cantonese these Cantonese am i me
right now you're you right now you're
jogging right jogging yeah I was beaten
off depends on how close like you
stopped to tie your shoe right and you
see him in the park like no that guy's
definitely beaten off and you're about
200 yards away I probably would stay
there how close would you walk to it I
don't know when put someone's jerking
off in public
yes do one of two things you have an
obligate depends on what he's doing is
he looking at you and jerking off now if
he's looking at you and jerking off if
he's doing it out in the open he might
be sick but he turned enough toward you
that you're kind of invited I think no
no no yeah you're right if you're in the
park this is just I mean being 100%
serious yeah if I'm running in the park
okay I see you know five yards over to
the side right next to a tree there's a
guy beating off okay I'm gonna stop
running and I'm gonna look at him and
I'm gonna look at all the people around
him and I'm gonna keep an eye on him and
I'm probably either gonna call the cops
or I'm definitely a stand there cuz what
if some person is jogging and he just
decides this is the time to jump on this
person yeah what if some kid is walking
by and he
as that kid and drags him into the
bushes this guy's so crazy he's beaten
off in public and he's looking at you
yes true I don't think I would go over
and be violent with him but I would
definitely keep my eye on him I'm not
gonna let what if he's a [ __ ] sexual
predator and he's looking to do
something to someone and you could be
like Peter Parker and spider-man save
your uncle Yeah right you know that's
what made Peter Parker become spider-man
he saved his uncle well he had the power
and he didn't save his uncle a robber
ran past him he didn't feel like he had
to do anything about it the robber got
into the elevator and it killed his
uncle I don't even know that yeah that's
the store wasn't an elevator I forget
what the actual story was but the robber
did something to his uncle and killed
him his uncle was everything that hunka
look care of him so then he decided he
could never let evil people do anything
bad again and he became spider-man like
that superhero I think you have an
obligation especially if you're if
you're a man especially yeah like if I
was a small woman and I was in that same
situation I would say call the cops
immediately you know don't try to be a
hero get the [ __ ] away from that guy but
call the cops immediately but I'm pretty
sure most dudes that are beaten off in
the forest like that they're not looking
for me right they're looking for a woman
or a child yeah that's true they're
probably not looking to meet another I
wouldn't tell another dude if I saw
another dude I'd grab another dude for
sure to help me like let's get this dude
I'd be like hey hey hey come here man
this [ __ ] guy's just beaten off oh
and in most men would be like oh Jesus
what do we do my cops keep an eye on I'm
gonna call the cops
yeah I'm let him get away call you know
so many runs by tell them - oh yeah
that's a see when someone's what
someone's really crazy like that kind of
crazy like some guy got arrested for
trying to abduct a kid trying to drag a
kid doing in his house and he had horns
on his head yeah he's got horns he's a
sexual predator and he's got those those
implants in his head were yeah looks
like some kind of stuff demon is his
ears hang down to like it's [ __ ] chin
okay oh great that guy's out there
that's a real guy just got caught right
so if you run into that sort of a
situation you like you have to as a
person you can't just run
way I feel like you got to stand you got
to stand around and make this you know
make people aware of it right say this
guys coming over trying to come over
here this guy is jerking off or yeah
yeah I think getting somebody else to
help but there's less of that than
there's ever been before but there's
always gonna be some of it so you're
talking about with pedophiles like how
do you stop that forever yeah how's that
possible
stop that forever and we had a dude in
school when I was growing up this guy
big Richard Wright and he ended up
meaning big dick that's what you call
him know this yep well we didn't know
this is before we were old enough to
know that dick and Richard were the same
no or dick how about this how was Jack
John I was short for John Jack is it
really yeah I don't even know that JFK
John F Kennedy John Kennedy Jack Kennedy
oh wow I didn't know John Kennedy was
the [ __ ] is that
yeah there's some other weird ones right
yeah we're never gonna get a universal
language I can't even get that right
it's from Irish that's how you say Jack
and Irish you got to look this up really
yeah John since they're Irish that makes
a lot more sense you enjoy the way you
say John I believe it I guess if you
said it fast and from far away cuz I'm
like Jack John yeah
short for Barbara is Babs yeah I know it
Babs actually is that Babs that's weird
short for Barbara barb is a rough name
though I think harm like a hook yeah
like and who wasn't a woman [ __ ] barb
all right now it's cute Barbies cute huh
Sal is like a man's name Salvatore but
that's a short fro well there's other
weird ones with men I know there's some
other weird ones that I forget big Sal I
know a lesbian named big Sal whoa what's
her real name Sally mano now so nice to
be called Sal but one time she borrowed
a man's bathing suit to go swimming with
us and I thought I was pretty impressive
no top or top no top dad hey let's go
she's [ __ ] so big Sam she was in the
shallow end too daddy
you know and that's a Matt's a healthy
gal but yeah I think if somebody I was
in Germany one time I was on a bike ride
and they had a man swinging his dick in
a big circle and I thought that that was
but it was a nudist area of a part well
if you got a new this area that's what
you're gonna encounter
yeah people swing index yeah I guess I
was kind of
sped off hmm you know I think about it
sometimes about big Sal no buts about
that guy in the park on what he was
doing why he's doing that you know what
I used to think I used to think oh look
at that piece of [ __ ]
now I think oh that was a baby right I
was a baby that name became this
helicopter dick weirdo why standing on
the street pointing to his hog spinning
spinning like that it's [ __ ] weird
it's crazy it's [ __ ] weird it's weird
that there are people that do that and
how much of that is because of
repression like that would if you went
to the most sexually liberated country
they have more or less perversion that's
the question right and how much of it is
imported like if you went to the most
sexually liberated place like and how
many of the people that come in are
people from out of town that are weird
that want freaky [ __ ] and then it
becomes an economy yeah and how many
people you just leave them to their own
just be chill yeah because we're pretty
caged up they say here in America it's
pretty you know everything's kind of
taboo and you can't see nipples and
stuff on television and yeah it's weird
but I wonder if that's also why we get
so much done yeah
you know like do we I mean maybe it's
just maybe it's my perception that we
get more done than other that were more
productive I mean it's I think we focus
on it a lot yeah a lot of things have
definitely come from here I think that's
changing right yeah but I think
pedophiles going out of style - I think
there was a time where more people got
away with it easier that's for sure
yeah it's hard to get away with it but
God that that [ __ ] that whatever that
is that makes a person do that just
doesn't seem like we've eradicated that
mmm it must be a loose wire and I'm
imagine that the thing about that is if
they could one day figure out a way to
get certain traits and breed them out of
people or engineered them out of people
like we're [ __ ] then well what if what
what would you leave in like what would
you leave in emotional outbursts would
you leave in the ability to have an
emotional outburst like
what the [ __ ] yeah would leave that
would you leave that in that's fun yeah
it's fun for me but maybe you and I
wouldn't be the ones who decide
would you leave sneezing in no I mean
I'm a behavior male okay more emotional
outbursts okay
like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that kind of [ __ ] that's
gonna [ __ ] yes I would leave that in I
would leave that in to not a lot of it
thought I'd turn it down a little and I
wouldn't [ __ ] with it
I don't think it's our job to [ __ ] with
it okay cuz you need that if a war
breaks out right yeah you can't have be
some guys like Oh gonna need that in a
war yeah you're gonna need that energy
you need let that whole like male
eruption [ __ ] crazed aggression that
you don't like well when an invading
village is headed over the top of the
hill you want that and a dude with an
axe yeah you want that you want that to
be available yeah agree unless we get to
a point where we don't have any war
anywhere ever again until then like what
but what if we engineered it out with
the Russians say they're going to but
they don't they don't they would do that
probably we would do that also
we would definitely always so [ __ ]
sneaky do you think that we will have
another war I hope not but that's always
the fear right mean we're in the middle
of two yeah well I think a could be you
think there could ever be another state
war in America of the blood go Civil War
States people some people were worried
about that some people weren't a
government some people want state-run
government well some people were worried
about that as hate for the Republicans
and hate for Trump in particular ramps
up and that they're really worried that
there'll be some sort of a violent
outbreak between the right and the left
and that this could actually really
happen man it's not impossible it's not
impossible that at least battles could
break out because people are [ __ ]
polarized man yeah yeah but I think
what's interesting to me is that more
and more people it seems like at least
from my perspective on the right are now
coming out against Trump
it seems more common more common
especially with this government shut
down people like what the [ __ ] you know
there's so many videos of people going
what are you talking about what
this wall like we need money like people
of the government people a lot of our
living check to check yeah you're
shutting down their pick is the only way
you can negotiate this wall this is the
only way you can fund this wall this is
crazy yeah yeah I mean it's I don't know
I mean uh
people always say the government sucks
if I can shut it down and then it shuts
down everybody gets mad you know well I
it makes an argument that the government
should be doing less things this is the
real argument the argument is some of
those things that the government does
why does the government have to do it
why can't it be privatized why can't it
become a business it would probably run
better if some of those things were not
run by the government like airport
security or like road maintenance or
like a lot of other things yeah like
don't have the government do it have
private contractors do it from real okay
yeah strong standards and and strong
competition and john stossel actually
has a video about it right now it's on
his Twitter page it's a long video but
explaining how one of the things people
are realizing from this government
shutdown is that the government does a
lot of things that they don't have to do
yeah it would be probably better for
everybody if some of these things were
streamlined some of these things were
done by the private sector I don't think
that's a bad idea
yeah I think there's a lot of things
that could be done better if there was
competition as soon as the government
controls certain businesses I mean maybe
they do it really well maybe they don't
you know I think that I think there's
certain things that where socialism
works really well like here's one fire
department mm-hmm
[ __ ] you gotta pay for the fire
department everybody wants to fund the
fire department don't ya cut the fire
budget man what if my ground no fire a
house yeah and we wants fireman we're
gonna pay for the fire department pay
for that [ __ ] pay for the police yeah
pay and everybody says pay you shouldn't
be rich people only get cops and poor
people don't get cops
that's crazy everyone would say that's
crazy yeah right well why is that not
the case with education to that well
right
don't you want people to learn things
but yeah when did education becomes
big business why is that a business it
should be our goal as Patriots right to
make less losers more happy successful
people more aware people more educated
people you know but instead it's like
subsidized by the government and that
makes even weirder and then you have
student loans you can't escape you yeah
a lot of that is pretty bizarre
dude it's bizarre [ __ ] it should be free
but there's also like there's another
like a lot some people don't want to do
anything data is true want to be alive
and they just they just they don't want
to contribute and really have any sort
of life and there's no desire for that
and there's generation and generation
and generation of them that is true but
what if what you ever would you ever
look at universal basic income it's a
weird idea i flatly rejected it when I
first heard do we have it no we don't
have it they've tried it out in a couple
of places but don't think it's really
worked out that well but the idea behind
it I'm having a guy who comes on soon
his name's Andrew yang this is a
proponent of universal basic income and
the idea is to give people X amount of
dollars per month whether it's a
thousand dollars per month and everybody
gets it no matter what and by doing that
you take care of all of the burden of
survival like if we take care of
everyone in the civilization everyone
occlude everyone gets shelter so that
eliminates a lot of crime and a lot of
strife just right away right question or
lay back where's all that money come
from there's a thousand dollars a month
three hundred eight million is that what
it was
plus you know that was 2010 it's
probably more now let's slate let's say
320 that is a lot of money 320 million
thousand so that's 320 billion gee it's
not what it is I have no clue 320
billion a month when that would be if
you gave a thousand people a million
dollars isn't that what it would be a
thousand million is a billion right just
do it in the calculator bro don't do it
in your head
thousand million yeah so that's right so
must be so that that's so much money
so three so the the wall like him
talking about building the wall isn't he
asking for five billion yet oh my five
mil okay it's not that much I don't
think well that's to build a wall once
this is every month you would need all
those billions hmm that's a lot of and
so that means everybody would have their
basic needs met
yes everybody get a thousand bucks where
that money comes from this is what I
need to talk to this guy about obviously
I'm not a mathematician or any sort of
an economist so yeah I have any idea
what they've how they feel like they
could do this three thought they got
that three thousand a more every adult
in the country Jesus that's a lot less a
stipend of 250 a month is that Andrew
yang it's not from him specifically but
it's a different guy from like guy was
talking bad about it actually he's just
giving you what people were oh someone
talking that's a happy I yeah someone
talking bad about it well yeah three
thousand a month is a lot yeah
that's crazy that's almost that's crazy
but yeah $36,000 a year that's I mean
look that would be nice right then you'd
be in the top 1% of the world everybody
over thirty four thirty four thousand
yeah thirty four thousand dollars I
think is 1% as it would cut the nation's
poverty rate in half well yeah but
where's the money coming from and also
do you lose incentive at that point
that's a good question is that bad yes
dad to lose incentive yes why because
that's what it's like the drive it's the
only reason otherwise you nobody
overcomes anything nobody achieve
there's no is that true is it the is the
drive does the drive always have to be
for survival or can the drive be the
drive to succeed and better yourself say
see look at it this way if you have
thirty five thousand dollars a year what
do you think you'd be cool you'd be like
I don't need to tour I got 35 grand
coming no I'd want to work harder right
I think a lot of people would want to
work harder because I think your
motivation would be different your
motivation would be to do better than
thirty-five thousand dollars but that
thirty five thousand dollars would take
care of you look if money was free and
economy didn't make any sense and you
could just fix it like that I would say
yeah fix it like that where the [ __ ] is
all that money coming from
that's a crazy amount of money yeah we
couldn't do it week i'm ii n-- no and
that means that were a lot of rich you
would have to give up some of their
money people aren't doing all of that to
that would be nine hundred billion
dollars every month yeah right he's
doing that am i right about that
three hundred billions not it's for
every adult it's not to give it to every
person oh okay
every adult you know see definitely
raise your kids they get the money [ __ ]
it to get a car three thousand no bills
that's true that's true so how many
people were dealing with how many people
are adults it changes to out this is the
argument they make does that you would
end some of the subsidies that are
already going on like Medicare and some
security and maybe welfare in some cases
because people would have money that
they're spending or they're getting now
so that money like I don't know it'd be
worth a shot I think it'd be worth a
shot but how long do you try to make you
know cuz then people are gonna be like I
needed more time you know right well
that would be they wouldn't ever get
their [ __ ] together there's some people
that will definitely do that
there's some people that will never get
their [ __ ] together and I don't believe
that this is a simulation I don't
believe that they were in some sort of a
video game but if we're in something
that was learned that you were it was a
learning environment mhm
you would want both to have your own
opportunities for failure and to see
examples of failure around you you would
want to see that like I'm not happy that
Artie Lange that his nose is caved in
and that he's got all these problems
with drugs I'm not happy with that I
love Artie Lange alright already lying
to be clean I think he's hilarious I
think he's a great guy the one thing
that could be good that comes out of
that for anyone other than Artie Lange
and Artie Lange's loved ones and friends
yeah is someone that's just looking at
him online and sees what he's done and
goes I [ __ ] that inspiration I don't
want to ruin this guy's in and out of
court he's always getting arrested
he keeps pissing hot it was easy there's
even something today well the thing is
that it's it's it's sad it's sad and
people love the guy and you see this is
dangerous yes drugs are dangerous yeah
some people it hits them this way and
for whatever host of factors are
he's got it bad right he loved already
so someone on the outside seeing that
could be like Wow
and that now is a thought in their head
if somebody offers them those same drugs
right
and so hmm I don't need to make my life
hit rock bottom I can look at this guy
or that guy or maybe someone in the
neighborhood or people around you that
don't get their [ __ ] together you could
see what happens right when they don't
chase their dreams right follow their
ambitions they don't they don't take the
time to let the people around them know
that they love them they don't do those
things and you get to see that that's a
little bit of your own education - it's
not ideal right ideal would be everybody
is doing great and we would all have
this big old [ __ ] happy community but
yeah some education comes from that you
get education and also but do you start
to even specifically with Artie Lange do
you ever think that when that sort of
become such a big part of his life that
I will like I've worried that that I
wonder well it does he is he gonna
falter with drugs and stuff it because
it keeps his name in people's minds no I
don't think so you know I don't didn't
think people was he was always a
successful guy anyway mom when I met him
he was on MADtv then I met him in 1994
the same time I met Kalin I became
friends with Artie we did a scene
together where I played a boxer and he
was a boxing manager I didn't know that
you know he did that show yeah man it's
probably online somewhere it's wow we
look so young I was like I think I was
27 Wow
yeah and he was probably the same age as
me or real close as was Callen Callen
it's just that's me right there that is
crazy or the boxer yeah dude that is
crazy
look at the shoulders though huh OSHA
what did you feel like to look at your
young body like that weird is it yeah
it's weird it's like a different person
yeah doesn't doesn't feel like it was me
yeah yeah yeah well you you look at
yourself you know from the past [ __ ] bro
look at you Artie
Ansem guy even already [ __ ] handsome
and yeah dude I had hair all that hair
kind of an illusion was it yeah I was
falling out it was definitely on the way
did you know you were gonna lose your
hair terrified yeah it's weird seeing my
body with no tattoos - oh that's
interesting at me yeah that wasn't even
like weightlifting days that was all
martial arts days dang bro strange I but
yeah the first time I review heard Artie
was just through drugged so maybe my
perception of that is that you know well
Artie you know he was a very successful
comedian for sure from the Howard Stern
Show from doing dirty work that Norm
Macdonald movie and a bunch of other
things
MADtv so many different things that he
did he was always very successful and
very well liked like in the comedy world
if you don't like like if someone says
[ __ ] already lying you'd be like what's
really right who the [ __ ] are you yeah
why you don't like Artie
yeah that's wrong he's the nicest guy
ever it's just one of those things man
you don't want to see it go down like
that you don't want to but you learn
from it yeah other people learn other
people do learn from it other people
learn from all kinds of things that
people do wrong you know you don't want
those things that happen but man they're
educational for all of us we're all in
this constant state of evolving this
this culture that we're in right now the
civilization is rapidly changing
everything is shifting oh yeah thing and
growing it's out of control man I mean
it really is oh and a lot of elements
even like um I was listening to the when
you and bill bird were talking last time
he's anybody's talking about like flying
around and stuff like that
and then he was talking about doing a
comedy special he's like I don't even
know what to do with it these days do I
just do clips do I put it like yeah
things just change so fast
like a year ago or two years ago to been
like oh this is exactly what you do make
a special it's you know it's like do i
well it used to be you didn't have an
option
you know the first guy who actually
introduced it as an option was Louie
because Louie decided to put his special
on his website and you buy it for like
five bucks which is a really reasonable
amount and it was a really good special
and it killed he made a [ __ ] ton of
money right and then people realized
that he made a [ __ ] ton of money and
then people realize how good he was and
then people realize how famous he really
actually was and then everything started
booming and taking off for him and he
was already in the process of happening
but it happened even more because he did
that then Netflix came along right
that's the ideal they shook it there's
nothing better than that
saturation that situation they just set
it up so they put their like we're gonna
get everybody we have a [ __ ] trillion
dollars we're gonna get everybody we're
gonna get all the greats we're gonna get
Chappelle chain Chris right everybody
fill in the blanks Sebastian they're
just gonna correct Bilborough they're
gonna just crush it and keep crushing it
and then anything else now like if
someone has a special on Comedy Central
you go oh I guess Netflix wouldn't hook
them up yeah yeah go to Comedy Central
that's how you look at right in the
comedy community right but I think a
real player is going to be Amazon
because this Amazon show the marvelous
mrs. basil yeah people love it it is
[ __ ] good is it
it's good as a comic I watched I get
nervous I get anxiety when she's about
to go onstage I gotta watch it dude it's
[ __ ] good the guy who plays Lenny
Bruce kills it kills it he seems like a
less seedy less problematic Lenny Bruce
but he seems a lot like Lenny Bruce I
mean it's you know he can only do so
much with it he's written in as uh he's
like someone who helps the marvelous
mrs. Melanie CD was Lenny Bruce CD man a
little bit I mean it's just I just I he
doesn't see the guy this is just the way
it's written doesn't seem like a guy who
died of a heroin overdose right yeah we
got yeah he seems like more together in
the TV show hmm so mostly it seems like
in the sheet
TV show he seems like a victim of the
censorship of the circumstances involved
in that point in time more like in the
future like he went mad you know if you
ever see any of the Ainge one of the
things that I noticed when I when I
really started getting into stand-up I
used to start I would watch some of the
old stuff and one of the things that I
found is you can I think I bought it as
a VHS I forget I don't think it was
online it was way before YouTube and
this stuff was available online you
could get old performances and I watched
Lenny Bruce Wow in this videotape that I
bought it's basically they're filming
him going over his court case in front
of a group of people it's really weird
because he's not really telling standup
he's just reading off of his court case
oh wow it's kind of interesting it's
interesting it's not it's not it's like
he's going mad it's going crazy because
they're trying to bring him in in jail
they're finding him and arresting him
and they're locking him up in jail and
they're ruining his career because he's
swearing onstage and what he's trying to
say is like you know no this is I'm
trying to point things out that I'm
swear if I say something if I say a
naughty word it's for a reason it's to
express myself I'm not I'm not just just
saying things because they're illegal
and I want you to lock me up he went on
trial for that oh yeah oh he went to
jail for that he got arrested many times
many times him and George Carlin look
the reason why we can do it at the way
we do it now has a there's a direct you
could trace the path as a direct path to
Lenny Bruce hmm Lenny Bruce started it
all off I had agreed to do some more
work he opened the door for guys like
Carlin and Pryor his you know there's
more it's all back then too but Lenny in
particular he had a irreverence to him
and this this notion to buck the current
yeah standard of what you couldn't
couldn't say you know he just changed
changed what comedy was brave did use a
you know there's people like that that
are these these figures whether it's
nikola tesla for technology and
innovation whether it's you know there's
a bunch of people like that in this
world yeah they just changers one dudes
like Elon Musk is another one one dude
Wow just salut look at this
Jesus Christ these these people that are
like that one guy goes off in a
direction yeah and I say I think like I
wonder if say if they went to the
universal um money for everybody right
you've ubi or whatever don't necessarily
think it's the worst thing in the world
but then you have as much adversity for
people like would you get a Nikola Tesla
would you get a George Carlin would you
get people if they didn't have to look
at the world that they're born into and
see not the things be uneven and you
spark some desire you notice what if we
get that I don't know I think you would
only have your needs met I think you
would still have your desire to improve
I think that's an inherent thing but I
think it would be more beneficial this
is just a wild guess I'm oh yeah wrong
it might be totally wrong it might be it
might you might be right you might ruin
people's ambition but it might raise the
base level right so what we're we're
we're operating from it's never the same
level of desperation so maybe we're not
as mean to each other right but maybe
the innovation still takes place because
people are always going to want to be
challenged and maybe it comes from a
good place right instead of from this
constant place of desperation right so
if somebody goes from a zero to a ten in
their life which would be you know
somebody that does something unique and
special and outstanding if everybody all
are automatically is given a three at
their base then now that person's gonna
get us to a thirteen yeah or maybe you
just don't have as much of violence you
don't have as much sadness oh that's
true because people yeah people were
violent when they see they want stuff
from other people if you're your food if
your food and your shelter is always met
like we don't have that right and we've
talked about earlier about like cultures
have standards and these standards
they're different everywhere and those
communities accept them and they don't
like it when you try to change the
standards if our standards here were
that all of our needs are met we just we
decide as a community if we're gonna
stick together and call ourselves
America we should treat ourselves as a
family we treat ourselves as a family we
shouldn't ignore neighborhoods we
shouldn't ignore communities that are
downtrodden we shouldn't ignore any kind
of poverty we shouldn't ignore lack of
education or a lack of nutrition we
shouldn't ignore those things so if we
take care of all
all those things from all of those
things first before we do anything else
if you had a re-engineer America would
you think hey what we have to do is ramp
up the military budget by 94 billion
dollars because we're basically arms
dealers yeah we're gonna make these
deals with Syria and Saudi Arabia
wherever the [ __ ] we could sell rockets
do it so yeah but that's what we do
that's what we that is what we do but if
instead someone came along and said no
the way to make this country stronger is
not make the arms industry bigger the
way to make this country stronger is to
make the human industry better right
make it better
let's fine-tune humans fine-tune oh yeah
why have we done that less losers
yeah 2024 I like Theo von run for
president that would be the best I'll be
your vice president
you like pants I don't do anything I
like that man hang back and eat chicken
nice and all the weird hair I got a P so
bad yo is it okay pasta vote in your
head go ahead good see we're probably
almost done anyway it's already three
o'clock go P okay go infographic on it
the EBI it's because there are the
argument for the positive or wanting it
is a lot of job they're gonna be
replaced by robots soon right
yeah these are some of the jobs there
that are at risk yeah they think
automation automation is gonna kill most
jobs so insurance underwriter ninety
nine percent of jobs are at risk farm
laborer ninety seven percent of jobs
artless Wow fast food cooked ninety
seven percent of jobs at risk
construction laborer eighty eight
percent
truck drivers 79 percent mail carriers
sixty eight percent
Wow they recently had a robot cooking
food I think it was called flipy they
don't remember where they put I think it
was somewhere the United States maybe
but they just fired it was the word they
used because it was doing too good whoa
yeah fire day because it was doing too
good that doesn't I get I believe it
yeah yeah that's a stupid ass ended way
of looking at it I don't understand that
stupid [ __ ] someplace called Kelly
burger it was too good that's so stupid
that's so dumb it's been sidelined at
least temporarily turns out the
automated fast-food worker created by
miso roebucks what a victim of his own
success 50 burgers an hour
Wow so yeah why is that bad it's better
it's way better it's better than you you
don't work that job now right I'd suck
at that job if we can find some other
things for people to do me yeah but you
know I'm good at a couple of things I'm
not good at flipping burgers what you're
not good at that you don't want to
[ __ ] mindlessly flip burgers it
doesn't even need a mind why not leave
the mindless things to them to things
with no mind so this is the idea behind
it but the problem is where's the money
come to take care of all the people with
the universal basic income and are you
saving enough money with the robots to
make it actually profitable to pay for
people pardon that if you save more
money and more money implementation well
Andrew Yang is gonna come in here and
he's gonna explain all this stuff to me
in a way that's supposedly gonna make
sense
he seems really smart and he was on Sam
Harris it's podcast and that worked over
there man this much urine I've ever held
I think congratulations hell is it how
much can you hold look out car D Drive
Theo von I Drive a BMW but I'm trying to
get rid of it figure you more for a
muscle car type fella really yeah I used
to own a 1984 Ford Escort and somebody
stole my passenger seat god damn it yeah
what are they gonna do with a passenger
seat I don't know probably put you know
put in the living room I would guess at
the time put in the forest and jerk off
dude how much comes out in the [ __ ]
forest bro uh yeah that's where the next
no wonder swamp thing happened well I
was thinking this once they found out
that in some plants some plants contain
DNA from salmon because the salmon yeah
we're used as fertilizer by the plant as
it decomposed it got into the actual
plant itself and you can actually
somehow or another through some sort
scientific process that I'm too stupid
to understand they can actually detect
salmon in the actual plant itself we're
closed so if you were whacking off on
that tree and that tree it's every day
that's your spot you went down to that
titty tree and and whacked off on the
roots yeah and then like after a while
you did an analysis and you found your D
in the tree itself oh yeah Oh be great
man if it maintains the information of
everything that walked off on it you
have a little son made out of wood one
day mmm you they had a kid in our town
of one time does he's got made his son a
wooden shirt that I tell you that a
wooden shirt
yeah he made his son a shirt out of
plywood for Christmas what yeah he
wanted a kid to wear it oh yeah he did
and I remember I was um wait a minute
is it a stiff shirt or is it he make it
like little itty-bitty tiny pieces of
plywood and weave it all together oh no
I was pretty stiff and the dad was a
yeah like an Elvis impersonator you know
what dad was an Elvis impersonator
casino or did he do it at carnivals
notice locally oh um but we didn't even
money in that no no money really I think
he's probably not all but he had uh he
had four kids and one of them he made I
was going walking home one night and I
heard him in the garage and he's making
like a son like a like a for Christmas
like a wooden shirt like a you know oh
there you go oh not as nice that one is
nice wouldn't shirt yeah can you get oh
but that's a like a sculpture yeah
that's nice can you get one more that's
like like if you went over someone's
house and they have a wooden shirt on a
hanger like and they think that's cute
just leave no now this kid needed it
because people we just witnessed kid
that's a man sculpture yeah it's a
framed wooden shirt it looks like he's
used to beat him up because of his
wooden sure know people used to beat him
up anyway on the bus
well the wooden shirt would protect you
from a lot of shots it's an idea and it
helped him wouldn't sure you better shut
the [ __ ] I swear to god he did a kid's
not walking around with wood over his
body like that not a daddy that would be
yeah this was your pads inside it looked
happy [ __ ] no dude do you think his dad
is estee lauder lady yeah see there's
some lady with something there okay but
this was early it might have been teak
then look up teens way too much
attention yeah they're posing pretend to
be aloof Shorthair by the ocean we're in
a wooden shirt a big no that's a big no
from me hey do you want to meet my
friend
she's channeling with her [ __ ]
geometrically patterned wouldn't shirt
on
what no I like regular people this kid's
name was Eddie can you look up teak
what does teak look like you imagine if
someone was trying to set you up with
that gal you'd be like well I'm torn
because obviously she's very pretty you
sure she's not crazy
she might have splinters at her tits
just dude it was one photo shoot she
doesn't wear that yeah except when she
worships the ocean I don't like now
that's something a little more malleable
teak or something like that what are the
kind of wood do they have over print
shirt now we're talking print yeah so it
was like that but a little bit more but
more real and he wore this for what
reason
get out action like a chestplate like a
yeah Roman soldier Todd would say like
that okay was it like how was it
connected on the waist on the sides
rather it was just kind of like a long
square it was almost like a kind of a
cereal box kind of where did he put his
arms legrest his arms on the side in the
side yeah [ __ ] your armpits up I was
limiting I mean look man these were I
mean the man that made it not a real you
can't do this my people would find out
they would call him out what ya doin I
was young you could do anything you
wanted to you know people that people
were I don't know just more fun you use
your imagination more when I was young
you have more fun how many kids you see
beaten your kid people used to beat
their kids oh yeah probably like at
least 20 I bet oh yeah people would be
polite in the street beat their kids
yeah you know yeah you see people beat
people up let's prove way more common
but I guess it's maybe we've moved out
of those areas too that's true
people back in those areas like bro I'm
on the front line [ __ ] still going down
yeah easy to see if he will fight man I
saw this old man get thrown into a fire
one time in a ditch fire that people
were burning throwing right in this guy
was in his eighties to mr. Pulido my god
why they throw me in a ditch he was
fighting a bus driver he was fighting
our bus driver and I'm the bus driver
threw in a ditch yeah I don't know why
was he swinging on the bus driver I
don't know whose fault was it both of
them both of them I think
I mean one of you know they're both
adults I mean look man I'm not surprised
they were doing it well you know
reasonable humans yeah yeah it yeah if
you saw me with me shocked they were
fistfight like what do you do with
people like that
once universal basic income rolls around
and there's some stupid people that just
ain't getting any better
basic needs met okay so then after that
after you do a couple years universal
basic income then what do you do
wolves in the woods yeah let wolves
loose go thin the herd it's insane man
get some dude out there jerking off
thinking he's hanging out behind a bush
he just turns these six wolves looking
up and they just know what to do
well you think a wolf would attack you
while you were jerking off or no [ __ ]
yeah you're all pink everything's pink
it has pink dick looks delicious when
you wearing clothes it's like can I eat
that I guess I can eat that I gotta get
through all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
plywood t-shirt once I get through that
I'll eat the [ __ ] out of that dude but
if they catch you out there with just
all pink oh yeah they eat the [ __ ] out
of you yeah yeah I hope I don't do
anything bad like that innate in any of
them see me you know I don't want to be
have that kind of ending you get
independent I'm gonna say right now I
don't think that you're gonna be jerking
off in the woods and eaten by a wolf I
might be wrong yeah but I would say
that's not how you're gonna go
thanks for not like I just don't see
that in you back I see better things for
you naked your pecker in your hand
imagine it's like you're about to come
and the first wolf built your cap bit
your calf you look look they're gonna
get me anyway
I'm just keep going on the edge oh yeah
maybe the bite and the pain cuz you're
about to come once you uh rock it you
you bust like you get more than usual
yeah and you're like wow at least I'd
I'd be my biggest load ever okay that
that's one thing you've always been
disappointed by right is the sheer
volume of your loads
well it's not much if you look at it
take at it next to sink in magnesium
really yeah allegedly egg whites I do
have to sink at the house actually sinks
supposed to be good for raising
testosterone Oh bro that boss at the
neighbors
the more you save it up - oh yeah gather
up more but I like to do that nocturnal
I want to ride I want that dream bus
that used to get super bus yeah dude I
want that dream bus never when you would
bust in a dream mmm those don't happen
anymore but they can if you search for
it if you seek it out yeah but you have
to not be to offer a long time to the
point we bought it bodies like this dumb
[ __ ] can't even jerk off yeah
I'm just gonna have to jerk off for him
like unconscious your brain [ __ ]
jerks you all are asleep what do you
think do you think that you're learning
things while you're dreaming because
some people think you learn things when
you dream I think that'll be one of the
next hurdles that we get over where
people are able to be able to take in
information while they're asleep this is
what I mean like they say if you have a
problem if something's bothering you you
should sleep on it and when you wake up
in the morning you'll have a clearer
perspective I believe that yeah I think
so too I think that's real cuz I've done
that before that seems to actually be a
good strategy if you can go to sleep the
problem is if something's really
bothering you like damn we're gonna
figure this out like you might stay up
all night and be exhausted and then you
might not be able to sleep and think
through it you got to get a higher power
to help you out man yes you got to get
us where a higher power comes into place
do you think you see yourself ever going
to church again yeah I would think so I
think Churchill is kind of evolving over
our time and stuff like that and we just
go to Justin Bieber's preacher Carl
Lentz you know he is hey whoa he texted
me actually whoa he's trying to groom
you trying to pull you in how you get
dark arts
how low low do you wear your shorts huh
oh I saw you guys make it out of this
room yeah that was a little wild huh so
you know him I've never met him
no you just text each other back and
forth yeah we communicate sometimes yes
that's that route hashtag dick route yes
and he uh looks good yeah they're both
camo - I think Jo shorts yeah but I've
never met him but all we go is chase
each other
yeah let's try to meet you know like not
tonight
you think he's somewhere erotic no oh oh
yeah that's a weird way of putting it
every time here you talked about jerking
off the magical problem it's like you
came in here with a gay expectation how
I got into it I jerked off yesterday I'm
not gonna planning on coming again for a
couple days huh do you have a time where
like if you've jerked off and it's been
like four days like man maybe I should
do something no I get that feeling
inside of me some it's like a vulture
that wants to fly out of my fry right
right okay brain you don't want to be
like two sex-obsessed no like there's a
balance right you don't wanna beat off
everyday no you don't want to not beat
off either cuz it'll consume you but I
think I'm gonna start hunting that dream
you don't want that [ __ ] nocturnal
bust so they don't start a group The
Ellen days bro there's late night
busters brothers dream do you how funny
is that expression I'm hunted in that
dream yeah I want that nocturnal Buster
hunting the dream but dude imagine you
[ __ ] dice playing noises have you that
guy's a [ __ ] MOOC man
a MOOC I never liked him Oh every time I
see him at the Comedy Store he's never
been nice
he's never nice to you no that doesn't
make any sense I don't know why no have
you said I didn't have you had a
conversation with him I've tried I feel
like I've tried to engage with him in he
and well one time he brought me up on
stage and he kept like they told him my
name a million times he never got it it
just got to the point where it felt like
he was like being rude you know like
making fun he might just be having fun
he's a good guy is he yeah he's a good
guy I'm a fan maybe I need to see
another side of him I mean I would give
to Scott it gets an old man just get to
know him dude when I was a kid I was a
gigantic Dice Clay fan I mean when I
first started meeting him at the store I
can't believe he's healer but once you
got to know him as an adult I mean being
if he's been always been cool yeah yeah
maybe better seem to have a new
experience with him yeah he's
you know he just his dice he's crazy
like half of his thing like if you go to
his Instagram page half of it is like a
put-on he's always [ __ ] around oh
yeah always being funny yeah that's true
but he gave me very good he's the reason
why I started touring he gave me very
good advice when I was you know select
in the 90s man he's like you should go
[ __ ] tour he's like you're funny
he won't hang around here all the time
yeah I was like yeah he's right I don't
want to hear on here like I should do
clubs I should make a living and this is
what he was basically saying was like
don't get roped into only working in
Hollywood and doing television shows and
stuff like that because then these other
people he'd control your destiny you
could tour yeah and this is from him
obviously coming out of he had the most
insane epic success of any comedian ever
yeah he was a rocketship he was he had
sold out hundreds of arenas arenas
giant-ass places a why remember when his
DVD or his see whatever would hit the
neighborhood and whenever all the kids
were watching it and I wouldn't even
allow to watch it so I thought when I
was listening to him talk I was thinking
oh yeah of course like this guy probably
made more money than anybody ever did on
a sitcom ever oh yeah
and he did it just doing whatever the
[ __ ] you wanted to do and he was
basically saying hey don't get wrapped
up in this only you could tour you can
make money mmm
I mean even if I'd never made money the
way he did you could still make a living
whereas if you don't tour and you just
do sitcoms or just work in television
especially if you work as a writer
that's the dark path the great stand-up
comic that becomes a writer
they never tour and they never develop a
crowd and does that happen yes it
happens a lot but weren't they just
supposed to be a writer then oh no no no
no no they gave in to the writing they
could have when we know great comedians
who mostly work as writers it doesn't
make any sense
when they don't want to they want to be
a comic out there performing and the
level of their material is far better
than the level of their notoriety mm-hmm
you know I see you're saying yeah
there's Owen Smith there's a perfect
example Owen Smith in my opinion it's
one of the best comedians on the planet
he's a killer that dude makes me cry
funny guy and he's
oh good his timing stage presences
delivery is material the subject matter
it's excellent it's top-shelf comedy
yeah but most people don't know who he
is
right that's cuz he's made a means made
a great living as a writer but he's
still he should you know he should be
recognized as a comic as well yeah
that's how I look at it so basically
what dice was telling me back then was
like get out go go someplace mmm go do
the road do comedy out there you could
headline clubs
well gratefully yeah I mean it I'm gonna
glad you did that because if we didn't
get you you might not be the same
comedian if you didn't say that yeah I'm
sure and I don't know you know it's easy
like it's easy to just decide someone's
an [ __ ] or you know you have one
interaction with someone you want to
[ __ ] on them I just think we should be
and I'm trying to do this myself to be
very careful when you [ __ ] on somebody
yeah when is it
when is it valid and when is it just you
looking for something to [ __ ] on right
like when are you showing no empathy ya
know when what is it now I think I mean
I yeah you're right I mean I'm willing
having new it you know a new experience
too late
you [ __ ] up [ __ ] he said his name he
said Mook it's over oh well I don't care
about that
I mean he's gonna get mad well he he was
an [ __ ] yeah so it's okay if I they
he just they kept their like he was on
stage before me so I was gonna go up
after him he was probably joking around
run yeah but at a certain point it was
it was just ruin aspect no it was looks
like he kept not getting it and then did
like I [ __ ] you know is this like it at
a certain point to me it was just rude
I see because you were probably a little
bit anxious you're going on after him
and then he's not saying your name right
you feel like oh he doesn't know who I
am so this is kind of disrespectful
there could have been there could have
been yeah I think that that certainly
could have been my party if I could
admit some ego and a 99.9 percent
[ __ ] around yeah he thought it was
funny maybe one he would do that if it
was if he knew you yeah he'd be like oh
who Bobby Lee right
he's alive I mean that's part of who he
is right
well maybe I'm and maybe I'll have an
opportunity to get to know him better
him and I Marrero hate each other they
do I'm great friends with both of them
now I loved watching him at MIT
seashores when he performed his mini
shores reunion our deaths
party but I remember I liked watching
him there you know I don't I mean I
think that he's a great comedian and
stuff that you know who what is he like
now though I don't know who would you've
liked have seen live I got to see him
live when he was really old and sick
unfortunately I love him man yeah he's
from near where my mother's from in
Illinois Peoria
yeah house I at least got a chance to
see be in his presence and see him live
yeah and he had this kind of he kind of
had this head bob thing that was very
you know who I think could come back and
murder stand-up right now
Roseanne Eddie Murphy yeah I think if
Eddie Murphy came back right now he
would murder stand-up murder it somebody
said that the other day they were
thinking he might come back he did a
thing one day where he was talking about
Bill Cosby about them taking awards away
from Bill Cosby and he did this Bill
Cosby impression and he did it with this
what does that say what happened pop-ups
come on the fire too sequel it's coming
back for that the movie oh really
well is our CEO in it too just he just
had his tenth kid Wow shoot just
shooting mad loads now there's a guy who
needs a birch tree in the yard 57 years
old he's 57 yeah damn it's amazing he's
only six years older than me workday's
or uh yeah six years old me there's a
guy easing Eddie Murphy's it's been
around forever did he was killing it
when he was like 18 years old he was on
Saturday Night Live but he was like 18
or something
it's great you forget how young he was
when delirious rolled around yeah good
lord
he was probably 22 hours old or
something would you I bet he can come
pretty far how far you thinking come
probably a foot
[Laughter]
we discuss we went over the world record
Jimmer
Jim Jim Carrey can come 30 feet back out
looks like a lot of dudes out there that
have broken the world record in distance
coming and you nobody wants to give me
any credit for it because it's like an
impromptu thing you know like you don't
know I've never Peter North was known
for he was known for volume oh yeah yeah
that's a crazy thing the bigger your
loads are so hectic that you're known
for them like to like if you say big
loads you say Peter North everybody
knows
think about that oh yeah but all the
[ __ ] substantial loads that all the
porn stars have dumped on all those all
those maidens all over the land and then
one dude is known for the highest volume
of comic you got to be known own you
know I'm saying you're right you've got
to be known known know right you know
time after time a grin you got to
[ __ ] bring that gravy boat yeah yeah
you got to be like you got to be like
the Kanye West of loads you have to be
coming and also probably look at your
watch or your phone during it and you're
still coming when you look back at your
dick you got to be the master race of
loads yeah you gotta be you gotta be
buckled up load like Michael Jackson
undeniable you think no he had very
little coming he probably zero ah but
dancing prodigy like he's the Michael
Jackson of Dance
yeah but you don't come much when you're
doing all that what activities you think
you do where you come a lot like the
kind of people that like power lifters
probably shoot giant loads right I think
you would think they do but for their
size and stuff they're not doing that
much I think she's the biggest loads oh
I think a guy that's in space I think a
guy that's on a cliff like a cliff
climber yeah is that the biggest loads I
mean that guy shooting some [ __ ] just
cuz he has the balls to climb up like
that he's busting Sonos tackle maybe
that's what it is like he's got balls by
those guys shoot bigger loads yeah like
BMX jumpers they jump three times in the
end and land on a bike yeah maybe they
have the biggest loads also guys who
like fake put a sign on the column they
don't pay a
meters like meters broken they just put
that on their car Viking still parked
there knows dudes bust some loads bro I
think there's other things too like
pickpockets Oh people that were up
turtlenecks do not come very much or
fall no what is the [ __ ] why keep your
neck warm it's not very manly it's just
a [ __ ] move it's just the most French
thing too and I don't care about the
French dude Wow but you have you been
there you just didn't register I'd you
this - how you been a France
yeah you been a Montreal I mean I'm on
trial you didn't love the French I love
the Canadians French Canadians yeah I'll
take them you love Canadians period
I love Canadians period but do you love
French Canadians yes because they are
Canadian but French bro not into French
and nobody is they make great wine
yes I'll true people go to Paris every
year yeah but they leave it's not the
kind of place people are milling around
man I think people go there and they
decide that it's better than America
sometimes didn't Johnny Depp move there
yeah
poor Tommy you know who else moved there
um [ __ ] the guy from law and order Mandy
Patinkin no Richard Belzer Richard
Belzer moved to France he'd met a woman
Polly then yeah I would think I'm in
love yeah bread but you bust in France
right you know imagine has semen
cruising down the street in that city
but it's all scooter out quarter
sideways
roads slick with loads everywhere
through the air crying out of the bushes
DNA [ __ ] manhole covers like the
clown Pennywise dude this [ __ ] is
getting gay bro this is very dick orient
today I would say it's gay well it's
that time of year it's spring people are
refreshed spring it's the middle of the
winter yeah it's freezing cold out just
January you gotta turn eight you guys
aren't open-minded why'd you say it's
it's spring I have the best dude we just
did three hours
did we Jesus cry bro this is the longest
I've ever been in my life now we know
we've done this before not this much I
think we did well how long was the last
one I think a lot of my three hours I
meant to get on some pills or something
to be able to go through this again
drink one of these nitros really
caffeinated yeah there's you see up
postures fun it was fun actually last
one was longer Oh [ __ ] limited bust
on this one huh thanks for having me my
pleasure brother anytime you got a new
podcast out with Brendan Schaub yep
called the king in the sting and it
comes out how'd you become the Rat King
what is that he just made fun of me one
time and called me a rat oh did you see
that video of a bunch of rats connected
together to pretend that they're a snake
oh yeah there was I just Whitney
Cummings sent it to me they do that
that's trickery I found it on that
Twitter you seen it yeah there's a but
it's on my on my Twitter there's a bunch
of rats that connected themselves in
there running together to pretend that
they're a snake that's a rat can confuse
well Rat King is when they all get
bundled up together and they get stuck
and they get their tails
twined up how the [ __ ] does that ever
happen disgusting creatures party yeah
they died that way too they find him all
caked up and [ __ ] it's a trap
partying bro
but it's a spring break dude this
burning man that's pretty man for rats
yeah look at this watch this play this
through this those are all rats all
completely bundled up together to look
like a snake so mama rats in the front
and all the baby rats stay connected to
each other to pretend they're snake so
they avoid predators and out and if you
and I saw that from far away we think it
was a snake a hundred percent yeah how
crazy that's amazing mother nature's
amazing man mother nature's a
[ __ ]
yeah we're limited time I think humans
you think this is part time brothers no
way they letting us out here fuckos dumb
[ __ ] could do is pretend to be
a snake and it can make snakes we have
make robot snakes shoot them to Mars out
of our robot dick we can't beat
avalanche though can if you're not there
oh don't go near work it's avalanche II
taking the sting Theo von on Instagram
and Twitter thank you for having me
thank you my brother anytime anytime and
we'll we'll see you tonight at the
comedy store later
[Music]
[Applause]